[Music]
like
all right people we're live on the
YouTube and I've got the sage of the
alt-right without the range without the
range of age without the range of the
order I'd been Schapiro welcome back
hands done dude all right we got a lot
of things to talk about I want to cover
a ton of new ground I read your book
over the weekend thank you for that you
have a new Praeger you video going up
you're still doing this daily wire thing
and a thousand other things so we got a
lot to do here but let's just start with
this all right nonsense
I hate that we even have to talk about
it's so freakin stupid but this happens
to be the world that we live in at the
moment so about two weeks ago but ten
days ago or so The Economist did an
interview with you I assume that was by
the phone probably originally yeah so
you did a phone interview with them and
they definitely nice the interview by
the way like I should read the
transcript it's perfectly nice a little
bit adversarial but that's good that's
fine they usually are Shapiro that works
right like the interviews themselves and
the thoughts usually stand on their own
anyway they they published this
interview and what was the title it was
called the Ben Shapiro the alt-right
sage without the rage which is wrong on
at least a couple of scores
I mean tries to portray you as if you've
got this evil rage within you all the
time sorry I thought that was funny on
it's weird because you've met made I'm
fairly calm this nearly all the time
there's about as rage as it gets right
here yeah so okay let's put aside the
Ray at heart the alt-right part and just
what the media is constantly doing so
okay so after you publicly then shame
them for it and everybody jumped on
board to defend you and you know all
these things got thousands and thousands
retweets eventually they did print a
retraction apologized they apologized
and they you know they appreciate you
sent a to where basically they just said
oh he's not party alright it's like what
what just happened here right guys just
said he's the sage of the all right
there's this thing called the Google
machine yeah and if they just typed in
my name
what all right they would have seen
probably the first result is a piece I
wrote for the Washington Post in 2015
talking about how evil all right is if
they I mean it was a review of the book
I mean they in in the book which you
have read I reference the all right I
think three or four separate times and
talked about how terrible their ideas
are and how evil their ideology is is
gross the whole point of the book is
that you're trying to show people
the Queen way to think they're sort of
right way to think so that you don't
fall prey correct to those that Western
civilization is not built on race
Western civilization is built on certain
immutable principles that's the basis of
the book it's the basis of conservatism
two or classical liberalism in all of
this is built on the same idea which is
that this stuff is not relegated to race
I'm a Jew okay the Jews weren't part of
that original white people bargain if
there was a white people bargain and
you're Jewish - I mean like that come on
I mean this is all it's all [ __ ] but
it's it but and I've done an open battle
with the alt-right for legitimately
years I mean I always psych the stat
just because it's a useful step but it's
true I mean I was attacked more than any
other Jewish journalist online in 2016
the vast majority that crap was from the
all right the alt-right still hates my
guts I have to have significant security
around me nearly all times because of
the number of threats we get from people
on the alt-right and I'm being called
all right by the Economist which is
supposed to be a center-right magazine
here what is that that I think is the
question it's like everyone gets it this
is what the media does they don't mind
they live a label they smear all of
those things everyone understands that
but what is it the Economist is
basically a respectable as yeah
center-right magazine this these are
people who you would think ideologically
basically line up with you so what do
you think is truly going on there is it
purely just the quest for cliques put
your Piero's picture up put all right
all hell is gonna bring it I tend to
hold by you know the Hanlan's razor idea
that it's mostly ignorant - not malice
and I think for some of these people it
is the ignorance I think that for the
Economist then they apologize within a
couple of hours I think it legitimately
was there was somebody writing a
headline who doesn't know what the
alt-right is they don't know the
difference between the alt-right and
conservatism in the United States and in
Europe the alt-right is a lot closer to
European right-wing populism then the
alright is to American conservatives are
in a lot of ways and so I think they
just figure anybody who's anti left is
alright I mean they've labeled Jordan
alright they've labeled you alright
right not the economists but a lot of
people in the media will do this routine
they'll they'll say that the IDW
generally is alright I believe I'm the
only registered Republican as far as I'm
aware in the in the IDW
people that voted for birdie yeah more
people voted for Bernie than voted for
Trump yeah among members the IDW I think
that's fair to say correct I'm pretty
sure that's true right I mean I think
Brad voted for Bernie I think that Eric
voted for Bernie I know that Sam voted
for Hillary liked it there are many more
members of the political life voted for
Gary Johnson right you voted for Gary
Johnson Cory I didn't but I didn't vote
at all in the 2016 election at the top
of the ticket so I'm not sure there was
one person who voted for Trump in the
IDW but we become alright because if
you're a heterodox thinker or if you're
somebody who asks questions and then
comes up with with answers that
specifically are designed to reject the
alt-right
then you are suddenly a member of the
alt-right just by taking the question
serious in this part that's really
dangerous right you see this with Steven
Pinker I think this is the best example
that I saw you member Steven Pinker gave
the speech yeah a few years back where
he said you know the problem with the
rise of the alright is that there are a
bunch of people on the Left who are
rejecting the question and then they
refuse to give an answer to the question
and so people go looking for the the
answer and the only answer they get is
the worst answer he wasn't defending the
answer that's the point the whole point
of his speech was no we need to give the
correct answers so that people don't
fall prey to the stupid crap that's
being said about race and IQ for example
but we can't ignore the questions about
race and IQ because otherwise people are
still gonna look for the answers to
these questions and what he's saying is
effectively the same thing that people
you know in the religious community are
constantly saying about you know you see
people go to Sunday School and then it's
like well I asked all my questions and
the rabbi or the pastor or the priest
they all said you know you're not
allowed to ask those questions and so I
left the religion well that's that's
what Pinker is saying about logic and
reason and Western civilized ideas that
people came in they asked these
questions and instead of the questions
being answered nor like you're not
allowed to ask that question it's a very
bad question and you saw vacas did this
to sam harris right when Sam was talking
about race and IQ and when people say
that when people ask about whether Islam
has a problem with violence right then
this is considered an alt right
perspective and so they'll ban Jordan's
book in Christchurch from from wit calls
briefly
based on the idea that Jordan has
suggested that Islamophobia is an
overused term and is miss applied right
that's welco took that picture with the
guy in the shirt the human with the
human and you've done many of these and
I've been on tour with Jordan I said
he's been taking pictures with about
30,000 people that's a bona estimate
probably
in there where he's had lines of
hundreds of people horse after giving a
two-hour lecture after doing ten
interviews during the day after flying
into the city that morning the idea that
he's you know investigating what
everyone's wearing or that anyone is
paying any attention to that
whether forget what you think about what
it would said unless unless legitimately
a giant swastika giant hammer or sickle
or something you like people are milled
through every ten seconds I mean those
generally come up they take the picture
they shake your hand they leave I mean
oh yeah you guys have done tens of
thousands of pictures I've done tens of
thousand I don't remember any of the
pictures that I took
I mean legitimately I remember the idea
was that he took a picture with this guy
and now we're gonna write now we're
gonna ban his book because then the
Cambridge thing which is even worse
right that was even worse but I mean
even the New Zealand thing where the the
notion that you are going to be able to
crack down on white supremacy by banning
speech generally is so dangerous and
listen if white supremacy will crack
down on I'd be one of the chief
beneficiaries of the crackdown since
then I mean they hate me right I said
I'm not gonna do it again I'm being
really careful about my f-word use we
got one of these I mean as you know
because we're friends one of the bizarre
things is how little like press on
camera how much I curse off camera a lot
of bombs off camera but good morning Ben
good [ __ ] morning and you react
exactly but it's but I mean New Zealand
legitimately is now gonna prosecute
people who downloaded the manifesto for
the white supremacists and I thought to
myself well I downloaded it because I
wanted to read what was in there so that
I knew how to rebut it I mean the
solution of this stuff is not to crack
down on species really scary all right
so there's so much I want to do here so
just go let's go with that for a second
so in a case of what happened in
Christchurch do you think actually that
reading it does add value because I get
you want to understand it a little bit
at least the people that are talking
about right but in another way doesn't
it just incentivize other people to do
crazy things because it's like holy [ __ ]
ben shapiro all these all these internet
people they're gonna read what i said
even if it's complete insanity and this
thing had conflicting I openly said
don't mention the guy's name
don't don't repeat his his ideas don't
guys never probably don't how much names
of shooters we won't do it and I even
instructed our people like only report
on the manifesto to the extent necessary
to knock down myths about the manifesto
and that was the big problem the reason
that I
loaded it was not because I originally
wanted to read what the guy said because
you don't want to give that credence
it's because the media started
immediately misreporting what the guy
had said and effectively doing exactly
what he told them to do which is report
on everything that I say so too so as to
divide people and then the division
itself will create more polarization in
society which is what I want I mean he
says this in the manifest and the media
were like yeah let's let's do that thing
which is you know it's interesting which
manifest does they choose to report on
and which ones become irrelevant nearly
as soon as they are released I mean
right that's a whole other show really
and how they decide what is relevant but
I will say regardless of like I don't
think it should be distributed I don't
think people should read it but if you
do pick it up and read it I don't think
that you should be arrested for that
I mean criminalizing people who
downloaded a file seems to me really
really dangerous stuff because you can
link virtually anything I mean they
again they tried to ban the best-selling
book on planet Earth from the biggest
bookseller in New Zealand because Jordan
was in a picture with a human like I
don't trust I don't trust anybody to
regulate speech that were they looking
to arrest people that shared the video
also yeah they were doing that too and
now they're saying they want to hold
members of social media hierarchies
personally responsible for distribution
of bad material this is one of the
things they're pushing in in the UK is
that they're trying to regulate social
media to the extent that they could Hall
Zuckerberg into court in jail and if
certain controversial material is
distributed via via Facebook I mean this
is not its own American is the easy way
to say it but it's not on European I
guess do you think that's wise uh Coburg
just in the last week has sort of been
hinting off like regulate me please but
they actually want regulation now well
yeah I think that what's happening for
Zuckerberg at the mall right exactly
it's a couple of things one is the he's
hoping for regulation from the United
States government because he knows he's
gonna get regulated from the Europeans
and what he's afraid of is being stuck
in this catch 22 where the Europeans
regulate him on speech and then for
business reasons he starts using those
regulations as the basis for policing
stuff in the United States and then
people in the United States say while
you're policing and you're policing is
not even and so you're actually an
editorial outlet now and you should be
treated like an editorial outlet as
opposed to like arguments for that I
think they can be done I think
do it for for a long time I think they
should be treated like an editorial
outlet if they're gonna act like an
editorial outlet but he's stuck sort of
between a rock and a hard place
whenever you see a business that is
calling for additional regulation on
itself you can fairly guarantee that
this is a corporatist attempt to crowd
other people out of the market and to
avoid responsibility and it seems to me
that that's mainly what's happening here
yeah all right so let's back up for a
second so after the the Christchurch
attack blue check Twitter went
completely bananas on you on me on
several other people and everybody you
know a ton on Sam none of us have ever
called for violence obviously of course
a single one of us have no problem
condemning this want these things to be
stopped or I mean I can see the glossed
over look in your eyes as I'm saying it
it's it's it's sort of boring tough to
say it what do you think our
responsibility or our our duty to
respond to some of this is because it
seems to me it's getting haywire the
people that when someone when 50 people
are killed in a horrific attack halfway
across the world when that happens and
then blue cheque journalists directly
blame you let's say listen right this is
you first yeah it seems to me they're
putting more of a price tag on your head
or are more of a direct threat on your
head than anything that you have ever
said I mean I think that's true I think
there's not much I can do about it I
mean 'men material that obviously is
libelous and theoretically you could
take legal action but I'm a public
figure that means I'm gonna take plenty
of slings and arrows and that's fine I
mean that's that's part of the debate
I'm the one are advocating that we
should be able to speak about this stuff
as much as we want to it's one thing for
the The Economist to label me a label
that is clearly not true it's another
thing for people to draw the attenuated
sort of connection between I've
criticized Islam's violent tendencies
across the world without saying that
every Muslim is violent or and certainly
not saying that any Muslim should be
treated with violence I mean I've never
sent any that stuff but if you if you
want Jewish theologians and Catholic
theologians Christian theologians have
been arguing about what's in the Bible
and what it all means and all of them I
specifically be insane to think I
specifically say and I've been saying
this for as long as I can remember I do
not analyze the Quran I do not analyze
the religion of Islam because you can go
through the religious tax of virtually
any religion including my own and
stuff that is deeply uncomfortable and
ugly and that's why I believe in a
reinterpret of structure I mean I talked
about that in the book and we'll get to
that I'm sure buddy but the but the fact
is that the balance between reason and
Revelation is very key to my thinking
and so I don't look at the Koran and go
looking for verses to take that I'm not
an Islamic scholar there are many people
who are there they're moderate and
reformed Muslims so I've had routinely
on my my radio show to try and talk
about the reinterpretation of Islam
they're much better situated to do that
than I am all I can do is point out the
by polling data there are a lot of
Muslims across the world who believe
some really radical things that if any
Christian believe them the media would
immediately say this person is a radical
Christian by any definition so I point
that out and suddenly it's I'm saying
that what now I'm calling for violence
against people who I don't know so who
do what I don't I don't know what they
not only I don't know what they think
but they're allowed to think whatever
the hell they want you can pick what you
want without being subjected to violence
I don't know how they asked I don't know
any of that stuff I mean it's its
absurdity on its face and yet the
attempt is of course to I mean and you
saw the media do this they immediately
shifted from what happened in
Christchurch is the result of people who
were critical particularly of Ilhan Omar
you actually saw this right there's this
move to say well if you call Ilhan Omar
an anti-semite then you're contributing
to just the kind of Islamophobia that
led to what happened in Christchurch so
wait hold on a second yeah I defended
Ilhan Omar being able to wear a hijab on
the on the House floor I think that's a
good thing
I wear a funny hat all day long right
like that's fine money I don't care I
think it's good yeah I would I came out
originally against Trump's originally
formulated Muslim ban when he was like
you know Muslims coming in I said this
is dumb this is counterproductive and
and it's intolerant right I said all of
those things because those are true and
then it was but if you critique the fact
that Ilhan Omar is clearly anti-semitic
then you are Lee like this is an attempt
to curb out to carve out speech right
it's an attempt to say you're not
allowed to criticize X because we don't
like you criticizing X and if we can
blame this thing over here on you then
that allows us to silence you on this
particular issue so what tactic maybe
are some of us missing to clean some of
this up because I agree that basically
what's happening here is there there is
these people have been incentivized for
anytime anything bad happens you blame a
few people that have some influence so
let's say you blame Peterson and you and
a couple other people because it's like
oh you guys are helping wake up people
to their own thoughts and to how to
live their own lives by their own
volition and and all the things that are
in this book so there is every reason to
attack you because this is what and it's
also in easy game because the fact is
whoever has been very productive in the
public sphere I'm sure has said things
that they don't like yeah I mean I like
this I keep referring to it because it's
true I have a running list of crap that
I've said over the pending since I was
17 years old I'm now 35 so more than
half my life I have been doing this I've
written legitimately millions of others
I remember everything I broke I've
written a column a week since I was 17
years old I've written legitimately
thousands of columns at this point and I
was writing like eight pieces a day when
I was a Breitbart and I was writing four
pieces in there for daily wire for years
on end
I don't know everything I remember I
have 140,000 tweets I remember
everything that I've tweeted so if
somebody points something out to me I'm
like yeah that was bad then I'm happy to
say yeah that was bad well you wrote a
piece for day you are correct here basic
and I updated I do update it will remind
me they'll be like yeah this was a bad
time like you're right that was a bad
tweet I did it back in 2008 and it was a
dumb thing to do and I'm sorry that that
happened it's like I don't remember all
that stuff but but it's it's really a
bad faith attempt to take down people
who are not like this is what tucker
carlson rightly pointed out and people
were coming after him this was not an
attempt to make the public space better
it was not an attempt to wipe out bad
speech that was happening in the here
and now because we don't have a time
machine right we can call up stuff from
15 years ago like they're digging up
interviews from John Wayne has been dead
for 40 years it's like well I don't know
you want from John Wayne dude is dead
right we can't take up his skeleton and
ask him for an apology if I say
something now that you don't like then
we can have a debate over that thing but
if you are digging up something I said
15 years ago all I can do is either say
I disagree with me from back then or I
agree with and then we can have a
discussion about what I think now but I
can't like I don't have a time machine
so this is all bad faith and it's and
it's really pretty hideous it's one
thing to dig up something somebody has
said in the past and then say this fits
in with their generalized worldview
right but to take something out of
context and then say ignore all contrary
evidence and then just say well this is
the worldview because I want this to be
the worldview so I can suggest that
they're outside the Overton Window and
we don't have to deal with them anymore
that's that's ugly and that's that's
what's happening I mean even there's
this video that was going around and it
got a bunch of hits from some lefty who
had taken legitimately taken I mean
openly taking stuff out of context and
put it in a video to suggest that I was
calling
for the murder of Muslims and it is a
lie it is a full-on full stop absolute
[ __ ] lie I mean he took he took a
section from an ad read that I do for a
second amendment group called the u.s.
concealed carry Association in which I
say that citizens should be law-abiding
citizens should be armed and they should
have concealed carry permits because if
you are gonna be victimized by a crime
the government can't stop that so you
should be able to defend yourself
he took the part where I say the
government can't stop this and connected
it to my video about how many radical
Muslims there are on earth and then
suggested that what I was saying is that
you should arm up and go kill Muslims
because there are a lot of violent
thinking Muslims on earth or extreme
Muslims on earth that now I'm suggesting
you should preemptively take action
because the government can't protect you
I mean he was legitimately taking two
disconnected thoughts on two separate
topics cobbling them together and then
suggesting that was my position was just
trying to open lie was this a public
person is this is an actual make you
anything yeah there's a human yeah so
what do you do in a case like that okay
you can defend yourself and yet it we've
all done this but I'm starting to think
that that's not enough and it's an odd
place and I had Robert Barnes here a
couple weeks yeah a lawyer and it's like
it's an odd place for the free speech
guys to be going we have to figure out
what are the legal protections around
speech because it's so not and I hate it
like in the worst position for me to
possibly be right think and yet here we
are I mean you're just defending
yourself well the guy's just gonna keep
doing it right you get him clicks
congratulations right and that is what
it is
you know I'm loathe to either change
libel or defamation laws in the United
States I'd prefer that people say more
rather than less now I I think most
people see through this nonsense and if
I didn't think that that we couldn't
really have a republic is the truth but
it's but yeah I mean it's it's obviously
deeply disturbing and as a good person
the first thing that happens you know if
you're trying to be good like I'm I
don't think I think I'm a person who's
trying to be the person and I think most
people who are trying to be good people
when you are critique the first thing
you think is okay is that true and your
first instinct is did I do something
wrong
and then the more you think they're like
no I didn't this is just [ __ ] yes oh
I I mean other than just calling it out
when it occurs I'm not sure what else
people can do and and and even giving it
airtime is a problem because then it
just drives them to double-down in
response and then suggest no no now he's
now he's lying because they wouldnt want
to read into what they what they want to
read it you can't have a good-faith
discussion this way and it's not meant
to be a good-faith discuss how much do
you think is just they want to take you
out versus just they want to scare
everybody else like it's pretty clear to
me they're not gonna take you out out of
fear right like they're not going I mean
III think that it's it's two it's two
things one there's always the pipe dream
that they'll be able to take somebody
like me out but I think that it's about
more than that it's about making sure
that people who are considered inside
the Overton Window won't even have a
conversation with people like me so
Andrew yang comes on my Sunday special
and it's great I mean it's a really
tolerant civil conversation I took his
ideas seriously I read his book I let
him speak his piece it was really nice
very nice guy I've invited every major
Democratic candidate on but a judge had
suggested that he was going to come out
at one point and then he just never has
responded yet I'd love to have him on
and ask him some questions and it would
be very simple because the Sunday
special is a very civil place and that's
a yang has gotten excoriated by the left
for even coming on the show right Joe
Rogan has me on his show and he gets hit
by the left with you're having on that
white supremacist Shapiro you're gonna
get hit just for having me on that's the
way this works because if they can
alienate enough people by saying okay
well we can't come if we can deep
platform everybody then it's it's a easy
way of avoiding actually having to
regulate what you do is you just make it
deeply uncomfortable and so we sort of
you know do I really want the flack of
having on and quietly shift that orbit
in window well I guess I gotta go this
way you keep moving it left right to the
point that any that everybody and the
truth is that that's an effective tech
is specifically because there is an
Overton Window I mean it does exist
there are people I wouldn't have on my
Sunday special there are people who I
wouldn't I wouldn't appear with yeah I
mean I've said that before and so
because that's a little murkier of a
line it's easier to manipulate that line
it's easier to say okay well since we
all accept that there is this Overton
Window then we can use that Overton
Window and shift the line here and there
now it's interesting the Overton Window
is constantly shifting as you say left
in every direction meaning that you can
express the wildest most insane views on
the left and still be considered well
inside the Overton Window and if you are
as heterodox as Sam Harris a Hillary
Clinton supporter who has said a couple
of heterodox things like I like I want
to look at the evidence on IQ and then
analyze how much of that is
environmental
much of that is genetic and I want to
look at how much that affects
disparities overall or I'm saying that
you know Islam has a relationship with
violence globally speaking those
heterodox opinions mean they're I mean
they're they'll rule out Sam before they
rule out Maxine Waters right that's the
way that this works they'll rule out
anybody Christina Hoff Sommers is too
far right for them she's she's a white
supremacist now bigot but they'll keep
expanding that all the way to the point
where anybody's wild opinion is
acceptable like the right is routinely
throwing people out for expressing
opinions that we find unpleasant outside
of our norm right when Steve King came
finally said kind of openly the white
nationalist comment to the Maritimes we
threw him out took away his committee
assignments I donated the max to his
opponent I raised money for Kevin
Feenstra who's running in his district
right and and the left response was why
was he even a part of you wants took a
picture I took a picture with him right
picture before he said any before he
said that stuff it was open right
exactly and so that's what it becomes is
what were you once nice to this person
it's like well that was before and also
you guys are roots like Louis Farrakhan
is still a person who meets with members
of the Democratic caucus like what what
why is it the the window only shifts in
one direction I'm not gonna listen to
people who tell me about who should be
inside the Overton Window when they
legitimately refuse to throw anyone
outside the Overton Window no matter how
vile they are Ilhan Omar just got
defended by the entire Democratic
Congress after saying for three
anti-semitic things in the course of
seven weeks right shoes defended by the
Democratic caucus and left with her
position on the Foreign Affairs
Committee well because they're afraid
that their own tactics will be used
against them so I would imagine which
they were inviting an hour well but I
mean I've been calling this river and it
eventually will happen to Bernie to it
has to happen that's that's the nature
of the beast how much of this though do
you think is jet that by because I see
this now cuz I get a lot of former
former lefties let's say even some
who've been on this show who publicly
they're like this thing the left has
just burned we we get what it is but
publicly they won't say that they've
shifted or that they're evolving or that
if you're an old-school liberal you you
can actually be ok with a lot of
conservative ideas right or conservative
people because there's a protection
involved this is right
you're basically a Democrat or on the
Left Joe Biden can run around with the
gazillion videos of sniffing girl's hair
and cramping people and all of that and
yet the people that were going crazy
over Kavanagh have nothing to say about
that but there's just a protection you
get as a lefty that you simply don't get
and it's and it's comfortable not to
raise your head above the waterline I
mean I would I like told stories on my
birthday so I have a lot of a lot of
friends in the media or people who I'm
friendly with I wouldn't call them
friends because of this not because of
this people I'm acquaintances would they
consider you well they know that that
really is the question because it's my
birthday right I routinely which people
might disagree with happy birthday
online it seems like a basic thing of
courtesy it's it's somebody's birthday
there on the left fine it's your
birthday happy birthday people will text
me on the left happy birthday
I can't do this probably they will not
tweet happy birthday because they are
afraid that if they tweet happy birthday
they have then given me the credence of
I was born and therefore I'm a human
being yeah and they're gonna get hit
with how dare you wish this terrible
person this this Orthodox Jewish
neo-nazi how dare you wish that person
happy birthday right the effect of being
dupe lost is the thing I mean the
Duplass thing I thought was so telling
and it was so and everybody knew gut
level that if you said that a person on
the other side is a human being that you
get hit but it's funny I don't get this
from the right meaning that I say Andrew
yang is a human right he's running for
the 2020 nomination I treat him really
well I think is he the intelligent guy I
think he's a nice guy
I've said about but I've never met he
seems like a nice person like I will say
that about the vast majority of people
who I disagree with on the left that
they're nice people who I disagree with
there's some more badly motivated and
those people I try to avoid but the vast
majority of them are like people you'd
want to hang out with and seem like nice
people he can have a conversation with
when is the last time somebody has ever
said that without somebody yeah on the
right they're a nice but Joe Biden you
recall this actually happened to Biden
so Biden said this about pens right he
said pence was a nice person yeah and
then Biden got hit so hard that he
backed off of it and he was like well
you know what no one can hold the
beliefs that Mike Pence can has and
still be a nice person then I'm sorry we
can't have a politics if the idea is
that we are that you are my enemy then
we are no longer even operating in the
same sphere then my politics make me
evil but your politics make you a nice
person how am I supposed to have a
conversation with you on that basis so
do you think then that Biden is
the last chance for any Democrat to be
somewhat centrist or decent for all the
disagreement you may have with Biden I
mean even the less I think it's seen not
only with the pence thing but he had to
double down with a whole bunch apology
Tory and he's on the apology tour but
but when you see how radical the
Democrats have gone and again this is
like everything I was fighting against
for all these years you know yet this
was like guys this is going to happen if
we don't start fixing it right now I
don't even think it's my job to fix
anymore it has to just sort of burn it's
just it's a that's very unfortunate
because I think as Jordan would say you
need a certain tension between the right
and the left that's an equal tension
let's say but do you think Biden's like
the last chance for that for anything
that's sort of I think that Google
Democrat yeah I think they're carving
out his soul right now and so we'll see
where he stands by the I mean they've
taken basically an ice cream scoop and
gone through his innards with this and I
just I don't know how much' biden is
gonna be left at the end of this I think
Biden's initial instincts and I really
don't like Joe Biden as a politician I
think he fibs a lot I don't like his
policies but I think his initial
instinct before he gets political is
that he can talk with people on the
other side of the outs why he's friends
McCain for so many years in all of this
III think that this is being beat out of
him in the primaries yeah because it's
just unacceptable
I was hoping the same thing was true
about about Budaj edge right I was I was
hoping the booty shush was gonna be that
right he said something like you know I
don't like the position of Dan Cathy the
head of chick-fil-a but they make the
chicken so I'll eat there and I was like
well that's refreshing
isn't that a nice thing like I know but
that was that was the only moderate
thing I've heard in the entire
Democratic primary and now Buddha's
Rouge is switching and it's again Mike
Pence hates me Mike Pence is out to get
me because he's a bad guy and if Mike
Pence thinks that I'm a bad person what
he's really doing is he's rejecting God
because God made me the way that I am
it's like whatever Mike Pence's views on
the sinfulness of homosexual activity
Mike Pence has treated bootie dredge
really well I mean there's a bunch of
records of him like when bootie shush
was activated in the military pence
personally called him up to wish him
best of luck in all of that like he's
never said a bad word about Buddha
Jenner as far as I'm aware our friend
Rick Renault who is the ambassador to
Germany who's gay right has only good
things to say about Mike Pence I'm not
saying that everything Mike Spence says
or believes would line up with
everything I believe but pret Trump has
also been president
for two-plus years are they coming for
the gays right it's in bring anyone with
you the fact that moody judge has to
make up a fake Mike Pence Yeah right
where where Pence is now his enemy and
out to get him is just it's really
telling about the the polarization of
politics and the attempt to shift
political differences into character
assassination this idea that pence
disagrees with me about same-sex
marriage and therefore he actually hates
me and it's like well you have no
evidence whatsoever that that is the
case like but we're allowed to hate
other people as long as you don't want
laws that are different for that right
we're allowed to hate people it just is
right I need to be meaner do I have to
not like I mean I I and and I think more
importantly you are allowed to dislike
the behavior in which others engage so
long as you are not attempting to compel
them to either engage or not engage in
behavior like this is well I think that
there's a fundamental distinction that
every religious person understands and a
lot of non-religious people don't when
it comes to issues like homosexual
marriage or same-sex marriage which is I
don't like a lot of things that people
do I'm a religious person right that
means that there are a lot of things
that Jews do like you don't sell it but
you're you don't take off Shabbat right
they actually been trying through a
little bit more right well that's good
bottom line is you or anybody or anybody
else lots of Jews don't celebrate
Shabbat that's a sin from where I sit
right that doesn't mean that I just like
you right I mean I said all the time
right I've violated Shabbat before
either by accident or a while ago when I
wasn't from on purpose like that I I do
stuff in my daily life all the time
where I think am i sinning like the
religion on a perfect human being well
this is it but this is the religious
thing religious people understand that
nobody is and so when we look at
somebody engaging in a behavior that we
deem sinful it's like we're sitting
there all day going on well look at that
sinner it's like well right that's
that's human beings right we all sin
that's what we do and as long as I'm not
trying to compel you not to engage in
the sin what do you even care like it's
connecting three times have I said to
your face I actually don't care what
your most personal belief is on gay
marriage I genuinely don't care
I'd write so be clipped a zillion ways
to sound people now you're anti-gay not
rubens you know and it's like but I'd
really want that and I said on your ship
you were out there right now if you were
campaigning for people that wanted to
flip gay marriage or or every day you
were doing diatribes about how evil gay
people are and right then we would
a problem right but by you taking the
libertarian position and your and maybe
from from your moral Center and will
shortly you're not thrilled with it okay
right I guess what I lived in the
country with people that I don't agree
with that's it and this has been my
perspective I mean I said this on on
Rogen's show this is like there are
legitimately millions of people in this
country who believe that I will go to
hell because I don't believe in Jesus
and you know what I think about that I
don't care I don't care like it makes no
difference to me fine
you're not coming after me that's the
best thing that's happened to Jews in
thousands of years that people aren't
coming after like good you know believe
what you want as long as you're nice to
me and as long as you are and as long as
you and I don't even think you have to
be nice well I know I mean as long as
you are yes first of all you don't have
to be right I mean like you made Sybil
as long as your siblings right and as
long as you're not using the government
to compel me to do things and when I say
nice to me I mean if you're not like
people look if we're talking about if I
like somebody or not if you're overtly
mean to me I'm not gonna like you but
when it comes to politics as long as
you're not trying to compel me I don't
even care whether you like me or not or
I like you or not I mean that's this is
why in my view libertarianism is maybe
the only way we're ever gonna be able to
survive this stuff because if we don't
leave each other alone we're just gonna
Club each other into submission I mean
that's why I've been ranting and raving
about all this all right so let's let's
shift to the book a little bit so I
really enjoyed it and then this morning
you put up or a Prager you put up a
video that basically is in conjunction
with the book so first off the title the
right side of history that's what the
lefty is always saying right when you
might hang that phrase let's talk about
that for a second because that's what
they always say every time a
conservative or anyone on the right
remotely says anything they always say
you're on the wrong side of history
right so Obama most famously used that
to talk about same-sex marriage right if
you were anti-same-sex marriage then
this meant you were in the wrong side of
history and this who was the guy that
ran against games yeah that's correct he
was on the wrong side of history at that
point though then he became on the right
side of history the reason that I used
the phrase obviously was a bit of a poke
in the eye to that phrase and it's a
play on words as the you know the
conservative side of history the right
side of history but now there's but
there's also this idea that what I don't
like is using history as a club to beat
someone with when it hasn't unfolded yet
so people will say you're on the wrong
so you don't agree with me on tax policy
well that's because in the future it
will be proved that I was right and you
were wrong and you were on the wrong
side of history that's what Obama was
saying about same-sex marriage was
people who are saying that traditional
marriage has been acts for thousands of
years those people are on the wrong side
of history because history will justify
my position and they will have been
shown to be non progressive and non
decent maybe that's right maybe that's
wrong you don't know yet history hasn't
progressed yet right but there are
certain things it would be very scary
though if that was true that we would
once things change that you would look
back and think that the thousands of
years before you and this is sort of
what you're talking about the book that
all of the people that believe different
things were backwards or evil or on the
wrong side of things I mean it takes in
no context of how they lived right and
again I think there's a difference
between looking bit saying here's a
bunch of good stuff that we have in
today's society and here's all the
things that we love where did that come
from that's when I say the right side of
history here's the stuff that we know
that is right and where did that come
from okay so that's the right side of
history
as opposed to here's my politics today
is my political position I have not a
lot of evidence historically that it's
gonna work or it's not gonna work but it
will be proved one day that you were on
the wrong side of history if you oppose
me
you're not really talking about history
you're talking about you know you are
you're basically forecasting into the
future something that you can't possibly
know so that sort of use of the phrases
is highly irritating to me especially
because there are times when there are
politics in the ascendency they're
really ugly and are proved later to be
completely wrong I mean there was a
point where Jews were pretty regularly
getting murdered in Europe they were on
the wrong side of history at that point
right and then it turns out that in the
long run they're not on the wrong side
of history the Nazis are on the wrong
side of history if you had said the
opposite in 1934 people would've thought
you were crazy so you can't really say
where history is going what you can do
is look back and say here's where
history has gone and here's what we like
about what history has been and here's
where we have broad agreement and that's
really what I'm talking about where are
the issues where we in Western
civilization should have broad agreement
and why is that broad agreement starting
to fall apart so you know the IDW is a
great example of this there is not a lot
of agreement on policy in the IDW
virtually at all but there are certain
basic principles that we all kind of
take for granted
democracy is better than dictatorship
free speech is better than limited
speech personal responsibility is better
than shirking personal responsibility
like these are things that everybody
seems to basically take in common and so
what I say is okay where do these values
come from because they didn't spring up
in a vacuum and the fact that we have
great material prosperity and free
markets and wealth and all of this great
stuff that did not happen either by
accident
or everyone at once so there's not just
magic it's not just some sort of
man-made magic so let's talk about right
and let's talk about the two cities then
let's let's start yeah let's start with
Jerusalem Jerusalem okay so the so the
basic thesis of the book is a very
strategy and thesis so Leo Strauss
famous 20th century philosopher he
posited that Western civilization was
predicated on these two poles that were
constantly fighting with one another one
was Jerusalem and one was Athens so
Jerusalem is the idea of judeo-christian
values that undergirds our social fabric
the vast majority of people who are
members of a community are members of
the judeo-christian community in the
West obviously and there are certain
values that are inherent in the Bible
that are different from most pagan
cultures so for example the the
judeo-christian ethic and we can discuss
where that comes from you know Jordan
would say that it's rooted in human
nature and then manifests in the Bible
people like Sam would say that it's sort
of an evolutionary hangover but you know
we can get to whether the revelation
actually occurred or not but the but the
basic premises of judeo-christian
revelation there there are several of
them one is that there is such a thing
as an orderly universe so this seems
perfectly obvious to us now that that we
can discover the rules of science that
things are out there that makes sense
but for a huge majority of cultures over
time that was not true it was you
worshipped various gods because they
were arbitrary they were fighting with
each other and you tried to appease one
at the expense of the other there are no
discoverable rules to the universe is it
weird though that you have to take a
leap of faith to get to a place that it
starts with order isn't it yeah it's
it's an interesting it is this is this
is one of the points that I make is that
people see reason and revelation as
intention but the point that I keep
making to Sam whenever we discuss this
is that Sam makes a leap of faith to
about these principles he and I start at
the same principles it's just that I
acknowledge that I'm making the leap of
faith to get there and he thinks you can
reason your way back using sort of a
priori reason to these fundamental
principles like the orderliness of being
able to discover rules in the universe I
don't think any of that is perfectly
obvious to the human mind
nor do I think that for the vast
majority of human history people thought
that people tended to think that
basically you were a cork bobbing about
on the ideas of chaos and that there was
no real way for you to to discover any
logic to the universe so the the idea of
the Bible is there is a God the God
creates a universe using a mind that
mind is orderly in nature and there are
certain logical rules that that mind
uses and then
we are created in the image of God which
has a couple of separate implications
one is that our mind reflects his to the
extent that we can grasp at a certain
level what exactly is the order of that
universe and then the second is the
actual meaning of that we are made in
the image of God it means that each of
us has inestimable value now that is
something that again we tend to think of
as perfectly obvious that we are all
valuable human beings but all was
restricted to the tribe for most of
human history and we are reverting back
to that now which is all you know we are
all valuable except for that guy that
guy's not value called screw that guy
right he's a member of an opposing tribe
and so the story of Western civilization
is the broadening out of that principle
that we are all made in God's image -
all yeah right that's why when people
say okay well Western civilization had
slavery and Western civilization had
racism is that all that's true the
question is why Western civilization got
rid of those things or has been trying
to fight those things whereas other
cultures have basically reinforced those
things or have decided those things are
okay and the tribalism is a good thing
so what do we do then about the people
that always want to focus on the bad
partner because one of the things I
liked in the Prague are you video you
made a point of saying yeah a lot of bad
things have happened right West has made
mistakes along the way but that the arc
has bent so that there is more freedom
there is more wealth there is more
prosperity all that but it seems to me
that and I think this is what's
happening on the left by and large is
that if they could step back for a
moment they might see that it's a lot
better I mean every college gig I go to
I go I always open it up to the crowd I
say does anyone have it worse I say this
- backwards yeah and they never respond
does anyone in this room have it worse
than their grandkids and nobody ever
says yes it's almost impossible you
can't if you're honest you know your
grandfather could have been an oil baron
and then lost it right they'd be happy
for that too they don't want inherited
wealth to go through the generations
right but the point is it's very hard to
get them to look in that what do you
think what do you make of the type of
mind that always goes to the worst is
that because of the disconnect
we Jerusalem I mean yes because I think
that to a certain extent you had and
this is sort of a thesis of the book is
that if you're ungrateful for the
society that you've been given that's
because you don't understand the society
that you've been given so we tend to
think of all this stuff as natural it is
completely unnatural dissapoint the
journal goldberg makes in his book right
the prosperity the fact that you have a
baby the babies will live to a
in the United States barring some sort
of cataclysmic health event the fact
that you are going to live not only in
relative prosperity but the greatest
prosperity that any human being has ever
known you can go on a machine and click
a button any product that you like will
arrive at your door in two days made in
10 different countries for an affordable
price that cost you less than an hour of
labor right there like but thanks God
those people aren't going to New York so
so I think that one of the great debates
of our society right now is that on one
side you have a bunch of people who say
ok well that's what things aren't
awesome things aren't historically
awesome you wouldn't want to be born in
any other time in any other place this
is an amazing place and all of the
problems of history exist but what
that's about is a struggling to maximize
the principles that were good in their
inception and then it's question was
fulfilling those principles and this is
true for the Declaration and the
Constitution and yes slavery was
contemplated in the Constitution that
was great evil then we fought a great
Civil War and then there was racism that
was implicit in American society then we
fought we fought ourselves using these
great universal principles and us but
that's always ongoing right that's
there's no end point at which all human
sin has been alleviated because we're
sinful creatures and we tend to revert
back into all of these things tribalism
and racism and and illogic and all of
these these things but but the
fundamental principle is at the root of
the civilization are good and then you
have a bunch of folks who say right we
have a lot of prosperity but look
there's still racism there's still sexes
and there's still bigotry and that's
because the actual natural state of man
would be the prosperity it's all this
other stuff that Western civilization
added and that I think comes from just a
complete ignorance of the realities of
history in the world which is that
everything bad that has happened in
Western civilization yes is truly awful
and evil and also has existed in
virtually every other civilization in
the history of the world the question is
why is the good stuff happening right
the natural state of man Hobbes is right
about this is nasty brutish and short
the natural state of man is not through
Sounion noble savage living out there
enjoying the fruits and the nuts I mean
that's not exactly what was going on
right this is the point that that that
as I say Goldberg makes is that
something happened and suddenly we are
all living in paradise so what was the
thing that happened so the and this is
where on the one hand I really accept
Goldberg and Pinker and the
Enlightenment argument and Sam's
argument and Michael schirmer's argument
I love
it's so funny people characterize this
book is anti-enlightenment no it's very
anti French enlightenment half the book
is actually I mean that writes portion
of this is about correct it to me it's
it's funny how people sort of see what
they want to see so I've gotten letters
from religious people saying I don't
think you're taking seriously enough the
contribution of religion and then I get
people from the secular humanist side
going I don't think you've taken
seriously enough the contribution of
Athens like no the whole point is that
these two things are in tension and not
only are they in tension but that
tension is necessary I describe
civilization as effectively a suspension
bridge on one end you have certain
principles you must take for granted and
that are embedded in the judeo-christian
tradition and on the other end you have
all the reason that must be used in
order to not end up in theocracy land
and these two things are pulling against
each other and pushing against each
other and pulling against and that's the
history of Western civilization and I
think the greatest balance was reached
in the American Founding and in those
principles and then those promises were
expanded outward to a broader and
broader group of people and that's the
story of the West as opposed to Western
civilization is that the Marxist take is
that Western civilization is effectively
a power hierarchy all these principles
are a lie and that the principles are a
simple gloss on on what is a reversion
to a power hierarchy so for example
there was a somebody on the Left who got
very upset because in the section book I
say you know we used to believe that we
were brothers and sisters we seem to
believe that we had these principles in
common and people like who's we Kemosabe
because a lot of because a lot of black
folks were not included in that bargain
a hundred percent true but if you go
back as late as 2006 2007 2008 you look
at the poll numbers people believe that
racism was receding in the United States
people believed that effectively we were
trying to get rid of all of this stuff
and the reason that we've been able to
curb racism in our society the reason
we've been able to curb sexism is
because we were able to use these
principles to overcome the natural
tribalism and sinfulness inherent in
human beings right so when I say we used
to believe we were all brothers we did
believe that we were all brothers but
then we expanded the definition of
brothers that was the story right we the
the reason that Western civilization has
been effective is because we have these
principles the principles are good we
were too restrictive in the use of those
principles and then using reason we
broadened out those principles to
encompass more and more people so I say
we used to consider all of each other
brothers that was true in theory and not
in action and then it was broadened out
to action and that's
made our world a better place so is that
part of the problem right now is that
we're in our eating fruits and nuts
stage here in the West we are in such
spectacular wealth and freedom and all
of those things and of course
everybody's not wealthy and we have
homeless problem and all sorts of things
and there's problems there's mental
health problems and everything else but
that we have so by and large conquered
racism we have so by large conquered all
of the inequities in society not all of
them but we've done a pretty good job as
they're saying it's the Train is still
going right but that that then becomes
the weakness but then people young
people I mean if you look at the
Millennials now everything that was born
out of this new progressive lefty thing
it's that it's not perfect so we must
burn it down so it's almost that that is
now but it's a symptom of the success
interest it it's almost a inevitable
symptom of this that's right I mean this
is what I talk about in the book when I
get to you know sort of the philosophy
of the 1960s which was we need to
replace the heart of stone within man
with the heart of flesh it was a
religious concept it was from a Marxist
idea which was there is something
fundamentally wrong with the Western
soul and what we need to do is shift the
entire system this is the Marxist the
actual Marxist proud promise is not
you're gonna be wealthier and more
spectacular and you're living standard
then under capitalism very very few
Marxist actually make this claim if they
do their ignorance the actual Marxist
claim is that it will fundamentally
change the nature of human beings to
live in different relations with each
other in a certain economic system and
we will become different humans now the
conservative view and the religious view
is no you won't right you're gonna be
exactly the same human you were before
the martyr the system can change human
beings are always what they are you can
alleviate certain material conditions
that make people more likely to be less
stressed for example but overall human
beings are sinful creatures we tend
toward toward tribalism and anger we
have to train ourselves to be good
anybody who's had kids I'm frankly
astounded that anyone who has kids buys
into the Marxist business because the
notion that kids are that people are
inherently good is such absolute utter
crap that doesn't mean we don't have
good instincts we do have a good
instinct but that is balanced with a
very selfish instinct as well I mean I
know there's a there's a new book out
I'm trying member who's the author was
just reviewed in The Wall Street Journal
talking about sort of the natural
goodness of human beings and their there
is some of that I mean look at as Jordan
likes to talk Michael to Piaget people
play games with each other and they kind
of form common rules and all of that is
true there's also a real selfishness to
human beings that naturally comes out
and you see it among kids and if that's
not trained if people aren't cultivated
to become better human beings they just
don't become better human beings and so
this is why I say you need to re-examine
what it is that's good about your life
and then ask why did it get so good you
didn't build this thing like I don't
want to cry I mean I do want to quote
Obama Obama says run build it when I
spend my entire life building a business
but you didn't build the system the
system you were born into right you
think that free speech is something that
just magically exists here and that
everybody is entitled to it welcome to a
thing that that only exists for the last
couple of hundred years and that
legitimately millions of people have
been killed fighting over is this why
what it's happening right now with the
Democratic candidates is so dangerous I
mean just in the last couple weeks so
now they're talking about reparations
they're talking about adding Supreme
Court justices they're talking about
there was a whole slew give me give me a
credit also the Senate because it's not
represented by population yeah yeah all
of these things that these are now would
be you know look these ideas were
man-made ideas but that they think only
in their day if they can just rejigger
the entire way we look at everything it
will be better where I would argue in
almost every I can't imagine a case
where if we flip to any of those things
things would be any better yeah I really
have serious doubts that if you get rid
of the Senate that suddenly people in
Montana are gonna be like totally okay
with everything or the people wait let's
not pretend that people in California
they're progressives in the big cities
would control everybody right and and by
the way the people in the rural areas
would try to break away I mean they
would that's the the I mean people don't
want to the Civil War was about slavery
and there was also a massive economic
gap between the south and the north
which was reflected in a lot of the
tariff fights that existed up til the
Civil War that was a rural-urban gap and
it's one of the reasons why the North
Lawn is because they had so much more
urban power than the south but you know
that that was about slavery you could
see a certain situation in the United
States where the rules look at the
cities they say we don't want you ruling
us you don't live out here what why
should I listen to a bunch of people who
live in San Francisco when I live in the
Central Valley of California I'm a
farmer
here why can't you leave me the hell
alone mm-hmm and and you know I used to
at least be able to punch above my
weight in terms of you you used to have
to take my opinion into account now you
can just ignore me and run roughshod
over me why should I be part of that
system I don't buy into your
majoritarian system where you are always
the majority that's not something I'm
interested in you know the the sort of
the checks that the founders did not
trust Pierre majoritarianism and they
were right not to trust Pierre
majoritarianism because majorities of
people have often believed incredibly
stupid and dangerous things that's why
they wanted checks and balances we've
sort of run roughshod over those over
the course of the last century but yeah
I mean the the fundamental disconnect
between conservatives and people on the
American Left is was summed up by
Chesterton and in his very famous fence
analogy that if you're on the left and
you're walking through a field and you
see a fence in the middle of the field
just in the middle of nowhere your first
instinct is I don't know why this fence
is here let's take down the fence this
fence it does not belong here it's just
dumb there's no reason for this fence to
be here get rid of the fence if you're
on the right your first instinct is to
say I'm not gonna remove the fence until
I know why it was here in the first
place once I figure out why I was here
then we can talk about removing the
fence and that is true right now in
politics the the left seems to be saying
I don't know any of this stuff is here
they even ascribe bad history to these
things right they'll say that the
electoral college was put in place to
protect slavery or some such nonsense
which is just not true and then the and
and then it's like what we created this
false history let's get rid of the thing
I don't know why it's there in the first
place no reason dump it and people on
the right well maybe we should like
think about what the actual possible
downsides here are because virtually
every action that we take has some
unintended consequences and maybe we
overstate the unintended consequences
like I think that has probably happened
for example with gay marriage right on I
used to be anti same-sex marriage on the
legal level right I used to say like I
think that if the government legalized
the same-sex marriage that it's gonna
have some pretty dramatic impact on how
people interact with one another and
then I was and then before obergefell I
said we should get out of the business
specifically because I don't want
anybody imposing their views on anybody
else we can all live how we want and
just leave each other alone and I think
the right overestimate kind of pushback
that you get from religious people on
that I don't know that we've ever
actually specifically talked about I
don't know that I got significantly
heavy pushback specifically because I
wasn't making the case that you have to
overrule your own vision
what's in constitutes I'm just saying
you can't impose that on anybody else
meaning that if you want to protect
yourself from the other side using
government for its argument then you
need to stop using government for your
argument I was making the anti
institutional Ottoman right I wasn't
making the case that everybody who's
religious has to reshift away from their
religious orientation I wasn't doing the
Hillary Clinton thing where a certain
amount of religious people I get that
that yeah yeah that I make obviously but
I would imagine a certain amount of
religious people if they're viewing this
as sort of a foundational societal
belief right who changed this
institution I didn't get a ton of
pushback specifically because I wasn't
coming out against the institution I
think a lot of the pushback that
surrounded same-sex marriage was a
twofold idea from the religious
community one was you must personally in
your own life accept that same-sex
marriage is morally equivalent to
heterosexual marriage and if you don't
you're a bigot and that offended a lot
of religious people people were like I
don't that that's not an argument I'm
willing to listen to because you're
immediately labeling me a bigot based on
both my religious views and a view of
natural law which is fairly common to
most religions and I'm not gonna hear
that I think that if the if the left had
approached it as you don't get to use
power we don't get to use power nobody
gets to use power the right is much more
receptive that's been my argument all
along so I think libertarianism has a
lot more draw than social leftism to the
right I think you can solve most of
those problems by get having the
government just not be involved this has
been my contention right because what
I'll say to religious people is I may
even agree with you on the nature of
sinfulness of particular activity but
it's none of my business and not only
that I think that if you make it the
government's business you know you're
all happy to use the government right
now for your particular ends but there's
gonna be a time when you're not running
the government anymore and they're gonna
come for you and you're not gonna be
real happy about it they don't seem to
like this Trump guy right yet their
answer is more government exactly so
that's why I didn't get a lot of
pushback when I suggested that because
it wasn't coming from a place of me
trying to castigate people for their own
personal moral views and I think that
for a lot of the gay rights movement it
was about that it was about it was about
I'm trying to castigate people if you
believe that what I do is a sin that's
because you're a nonmeritorious
intolerant bigot does that also show you
that the that unfortunately religious
people have been tarred with this idea
of intolerance when it isn't true I mean
is that like a really good succinct I
mean I think it's a good example because
the fact is that listen has
in religious intolerance or people on
100% I mean come on wait I can't pretend
that that doesn't exist in the Jewish
community exist in the Christian
community exist in the Muslim community
it's true that there's been intolerance
I don't want to portray religious people
is all completely innocent in this
because obviously that's not true there
are people who have been excised and
treated badly by religious communities
of course that's true but this is what I
was talking about earlier with with
Buddha judge his treatment of pence the
attract the attribution of motive
depends as though pence is sitting there
like day in and day out thinking ah that
people but a judge in his his sexual
proclivities perfectly that's mmm I
don't know anybody who thinks that way
if they do think that way there's
something wrong with them frankly and
it's and so that's and also it came out
of a year of me to where it was like
right before all that happened what was
everyone making fun of pence over that
he doesn't know into rooms with other
women and yeah that may sound odd to me
or you know alright that's what he's
decided to do and guess what it's been
not accused of doing sometimes I mean
frankly listen that's been in Jewish
religious law for a very long time
you're not supposed to be alone with a
with a woman who is not your wife with
the door closed this is like
legitimately part of Jewish law and it
has been for several thousand years it's
called you hood you're not actually
supposed to do it so like Mike Pence say
that I was like oh well welcome to the
club dude thank you what do you do in a
situation like that then so if you're in
your office and a female coach you've
got glass doors so it's not as much fun
issue right like I never want to be in a
position where I can be accused of
acting with impropriety and by the way
this is true for doctors to like I'm
shocked that people took pens that way
I'm my wife who is a doctor when she
goes into my production is it turns out
there but when she when she goes in and
she examines a patient when when a male
doctor examines a female patient the new
rule basically is there must be some
third party in the room to ensure that
there's no claim made against the doctor
it seems to me if you're a prominent
person then you should be considering
exactly the same thing like this doesn't
seem logical to me this just seems like
for the same reason that I like body
cameras on cops is a general matter I
like evidence and I like people who are
there to debunk or enforce the the the
actual account that happened so is this
another one of those things where they
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions where the idea of course is
you know we're gonna put everybody in
situations where
you I wouldn't care I don't care the
person that I hire I don't look at their
I mean when we did our last job posting
I made a point of saying I don't care
about your gender I don't care about
your sexuality I don't care about your
skin color etc etc but in reality
because the world is so out of whack
right now the truth the real truth is I
don't know that I've ever said this
publicly when we were looking at resumes
I was less inclined to hire a gay man
because I thought well I could be in a
room with this person and then they
could just announce there isn't there
how insane is that so now you've created
a because you create the system of
incentives that it doesn't help anybody
right and you've seen actually this this
sort of thing materially speaking in
terms of for example policies that say
that you're not allowed to do criminal
background checks on potential employees
because there are too many black folks
who have criminal backgrounds and so we
want to make sure more black people are
employed you actually end up with the
reverse what you end up with is
employers who look at resumes and in
many cases cannot check the criminal
background of people and so they say
okay statistically speaking it's more
likely that a black person went to
prison than a white person went to
prison that's not a racial statement
it's a statistical statement of fact and
so I'm just not gonna hire this black
person well who gets hurt by that but
that guy who didn't commit a crime yeah
this is this is the sort of thing that
the like there are dangerous unintended
consequences to public policies that are
that are well-intentioned again I think
it's a well-intentioned public policy
but I think that it's a bad public
policy and to pretend that people aren't
people is stupid people are going to use
whatever information they have at hand
to make judgments and to protect
themselves and this is this is true if
this is true with regard to employers
and women taking time off from the
workforce this is true with regard to
sexual harassment allegations like
listen when I was growing up my mom
always said to me right and my mom ran
businesses I mean she she was a
higher-up
at the company that did Hell's Kitchen
she didn't like major reality TV shows
so she was a high-powered woman my mom
worked my dad stayed at home and my mom
said to me if you ever get a secretary
get a 7-year old woman right because
you're never gonna be accused of
anything because she's 70 right and that
was my mom saying that to me yeah you
know some people have that fetish but as
a general rule like that's but and and
that's not entirely like human nature is
human nature and this there's been this
willful attempt to blind ourselves to
human nature that I find alternatively
hilarious and
ridiculous and scary that's like what
we're supposed to pretend that reality
doesn't exist because we wish reality
we're not what it was and the truth is
the unhappiest people on earth are the
people who are constantly fighting
reality whether you're talking about in
your dating life where it's like I want
to look just exactly as I feel like
looking at everybody else who won't date
me it's their problem I can't get a date
in school maybe it's because you haven't
worked out in 10 years right think yeah
or maybe or whether it's in the job
market where it's like well I wish that
I could get this job and I deserve to
get this job and I'm not gonna do what I
need resume wise to get the job or I'm
going to rely on such-and-such to get
the job that I don't get or or I'm gonna
sit in this dying town and I'm never
gonna leave this dying town because I
deserve to have a job in this dying town
the nice thing about policy says you can
pander to everybody by lying to them
about these realities did you happen to
see last night I think it was on 60
minutes there's a clip going around of
this young you saw this this student
yeah are they they interviewed several
young students and the thrust of it I
didn't see the full thing I just ranked
they tweeted out the videos that they
tweeted out but the rest of it was all
these young people but there's this
particular young man saying you know if
college was free and medical school was
free and all that I wouldn't have to
work and then because of that I could
study more thus I could be a better done
right and it's like a there's no proof
that that's actually true and you might
learn a lot of things by working and all
that now the idea that med school maybe
is too much money and college is
complete out of whack that's a perfectly
legit conversation to have right and we
can't have that conversation but I just
thought the way it was spun by the
Twitter account was like see it's
obvious you shouldn't have to work if
you're gonna be a doctor right and it's
like no no right missing something here
well then that's so what was funny about
that story is CBS News covered it as
isn't this a great example of why we
should make medical school worry right
and what actually happened is that there
was a donor I'd lose brownie Marcus from
from Home Depot who went to NYU and he
donated several I believe is like a
hundred million dollars to NYU to pay
for the medical education of the kids
who went to NYU so this is a private
donor doing something good for these
kids and they're like what if we just
made a government policy well then you'd
completely see you the incentive
structures what would happen is I'll
tell you what would be the next thing
that happened the next thing that
happened is that doctors would be would
be granted free tuition presumably and
the next thing that would happen is they
would say okay well now you have to be
regulated so you need to work for 60
grand
at which point the registration rates
would dramatically drop and you get a
completely different crop of people who
are going into medicine in the first
place because you know that you're gonna
get free education we're only gonna make
60 grand 70 grand on the other end all
those people who right now are paying
$200,000 to go to medical school so they
can make four hundred thousand dollars a
year coming out all those people decide
to go work at McKinsey instead that's
all that happens because people are
profit seeking and want to live a
certain lifestyle and guess what after
eleven years of this [ __ ]
like my wife deserves to be able to earn
whatever she can earn I mean I've been
doing this thing okay like I cannot tell
you how many how many things we've had
before ago and I've paid for her medical
education right I mean I've gone
out-of-pocket for all of it I've paid
for every iota of her medical education
and it's cost us alot when she's working
for below minimum wage right now because
doctors and residency effectively work
for below minimum wage they're making
forty fifteen grand a year and the work
in 80 hours a week and that's what they
go through and you know what
that's because they should make money on
the other end the market does have a
value in determining what the value of
these things are so you would say the
two solutions to that are either the
market or private people like the Home
Depot guy coming in at that it's just
it's not perfect but frankly I don't
think that no resource I don't think
that there is a so there are a couple
things you can do to bring down medical
school tuition one you could stop with
the licensure requirements for things
that nurse practitioners could do Yeah
right because that way you have a bunch
of people who are going to nursing
school or PA school and they can do a
lot of this stuff and then you don't
have to create this cartel and the
cartel charges a lot of money to for you
to get into it that that'd be one thing
but number two so what so you take out a
bunch of loans to go to medical school
many make a bunch of money coming out
which you should make because you have
spent a lot of money going in like if
you wanted the question is do you want
your doctors to be people who make a lot
of money do you think doctoring is an
important thing as a society such that
you want the smartest people going into
it if you want the smartest people going
into any industry you have to make sure
that the pay grade is high enough and I
my problem here is not free medical
school my problem is that it will be
used as an incentive to to force doctors
to take less of a cost from Medicare for
example and then you will get a less or
group of people intellectually than you
otherwise what there's an unintended
consequence to this sort of stuff so is
this just the fundamental flaw with
almost every argument that comes out of
the progressive these days that if you
give free college that this will somehow
ultimately do good even though we know
that there are more jobs disappearing
that
I think that you wouldn't need college
that nobody the freaky could go to trade
school or or any of these things where
it's like we can or Medicare and that
the free college education the free
college education argument is one of the
worst arguments I've ever heard it's
legitimately a terrible argument I mean
the idea that look everybody in college
is earning more than people who didn't
go to college therefore if everyone went
to college they would all earn more mmm
that know that I'm sorry the reason
people earn more from going to college
is because it is a sorting mechanism if
you get rid of the sorting mechanism you
know it will happen there will be
another sorting mechanism which is
exactly what's happened with grad
schools the vast number of it like as
you sort the incomes go up and as you
get rid of the sorting mechanism there
are new sorting mechanisms that are
added to the job market and to the
educational market well you're actually
getting unless you're actually you know
going there for math or science or
something but as I said if you go to
college and I went to UCLA and then
Harvard Law School so I have plenty of
experience with with going and majoring
in useless things at major university I
was a Poli Sci major UCLA which is a
useless thing at a major university the
all that these things are are twofold a
sorting mechanism because I went to UCLA
and not CSUN and that means that
presumably I'm smarter because it's a
higher SAT score to get into UCLA than
it is to get into CSUN and second a an
airshaft social fabric where you meet a
bunch of people who then you can later
on call on his friends ran this is what
JD Mane's talks about in hillbilly ology
coming from Appalachia going to Yale Law
School suddenly he has a group of people
he can call on and he's part of a social
fabric and he's operating in different
social circles neither of those two
things are going to be cured by
Universal College because the social
fabric goes away because it's not
selective anymore and the sorting
mechanism goes away because it's not
selective anymore right no so do you get
free College no matter what your major
well this is the other in lesbian dance
Theory right at free College right and
then what did we give to society when
you're not qualified to do anything by
the way
Buddha jesh is exactly right about this
this he was correct on he says why are
we having middle class people
subsidizing people who are upper class
yeah yeah totally correct totally
correct the people who are gonna end up
in college and able to get into college
are gonna be the people who would have
been able to go to college anyway we
don't need more people going to college
we need fewer people going to college we
need less useless majors we need people
being able to apprentice directly into
law school
we need like why is it that you have to
be 23 and you've gone through seven
years of education to go to law school
why it makes no sense why don't you just
when you're hiring right now because
daily wires can
you guys are growing faster you're doing
all sorts of stuff over at the office
when you look at resume I don't know how
involved yeah specifically you are but I
assume yeah Jeremy's much more involved
but yeah um do you even care that much
work experience matters more than where
you went to college for sure I mean
Jeremy's a perfect example is my
business partner didn't finish college
he went to a music school and dropped
out after two years and people used to
look down their noses at him I remember
there was a very prominent person whose
name everyone would recognize who once
called up Jeremy cursing in him because
he had not gone to college and Jeremy
was like why like Jared Jeremy now runs
a company that that you know we have
close to 100 employees we would clear a
lot of money over here.we gross a lot of
money and the you know some of the
smartest people I know never went to
college or finished college like it's
it's good for what it's good for and
it's bad for what it's bad for it's good
for pre-med it's good for math it's good
it would be I got a lot of flack for
saying this about about kind of the what
we call the North Campus majors at UCLA
the the the poly SCI English history
majors and I said like basically this is
effectively useless and you should you
know unless you're majoring in a hard
science you should think about going
elsewhere like well your whole book is
about Western civilized philosophy I'm
like right we don't learn any of that
crap when I go to college anymore
well that's the reason I wrote the book
is because none of these people learn
any of this stuff nobody's ever heard of
a client is when you go like when's the
last time they taught Aquinas at at a
major university other than in sort of
religious studies classes they don't
even mandate Western Civ any more at
these classes nor I mean like this stuff
should be imbibed with your mother's
milk I mean this should be they should
be part of just the generalized
educational curriculum so that if we
want to go down the conspiracy road a
little bit is that part of it too is
that if you really wanted to keep
indoctrinating people with lefty ideas
and socialist ideas and big government
ideas and all of those things and
collectivist ideas well give them free
college and then just teach them those
ideas for four years and then you've
really whacked them at the knees before
they get it I mean I think there is it I
think it would make sense Bernice a goal
everyone's getting freaked on right and
what are we gonna do to your college
teach you postmodern is right and I
think I think it's less conspiratorial
than that but I do think that there are
a bunch of people on the Left who
certainly are not upset about the fact
that colleges are dominated by the left
and who are very angry every time
somebody tries to break that domination
I mean this is why I get banned from
colleges speaking about stuff like this
so
it's you know again it's it's a hard
ecology how do you how do you take the
ideas between Jerusalem and Athens and
how do you then just beat the easy ideas
of the day because that's to me that is
where we're at so now we're just at a
place of easy answer everyone that I
disagree with is a racist big at
homophobe I know how to do everything
everyone before me was evil all of those
things
let's change everything the current laws
and electoral college and everything
else let's do all of those things
because we're so good and everyone else
so stupid well how do you actually beat
that I mean that that's what we're going
to do right I mean I think that the
first thing to do is to is to you know
get people involved in re-educating
themselves and I think you're seeing a
tremendous hunger for that obviously I
mean this is a book on Western
philosophy and in the first two weeks we
sold well over a hundred thousand copies
it's a book on Western philosophy right
now it does not exactly pop reading I
mean it's not it's not happy to have you
do kind of stuff so it's it Horton told
people how to clean their room it's so
five million exactly that's exactly
that's exactly right I mean like there's
a market for hard stuff right now
because people are looking for something
that means something and we haven't
created a much better world but with the
Twitter woke police out there I don't
think that people are feeling happy or
secure because of all that stuff so do
you think it's fundamentally a crisis of
meaning that's really what I took away
from your yes that I and I really I was
thinking about it over the weekend it's
like no we listen you know we fight on
Twitter all day long we all siphon off
into our own little places and now
between fake news and everything else
it's like nobody really knows in the
secular world like yeah nobody really
milk has this and this is the sadness of
liberalism right now for me
it's like maybe liberalism didn't give
enough through a secular lens and / and
I think maybe you'd argue that's because
it got disconnected from from Jerusalem
yeah Jerusalem people know that we're in
a crisis we're Isis of belief I mean I
think the crisis of reality here's
here's what here's my real argument with
sort of the secular version of the
Enlightenment the french-german version
of the Enlightenment which is that by
disconnecting the connection to
judeo-christian values the idea was that
we were going to untether ourselves to
be able to fly to the stars we can make
our own meaning and I think people suck
in making their own meaning frankly I
think that generally when people make
their own meaning they tend to fall into
hedonism or nihilism I think that what
you there
some people can do it some people can do
it some people can do it some people can
live with this I mean I think that Sam
did seems like a fulfilled guy Michael
Shermer is a fulfilled guy and I think
there are there are people who can who
can live with this and make their own
meaning but for the vast majority of
people the answer is absolutely not you
cannot make your own meaning because if
you make your own meaning you tend
toward either selfishness or
meaninglessness you need to be told that
your life has value and that you're in
control of your own life and there needs
to be a rooted rooted philosophy to
support that and that begins with
teaching these very simple stories I
mean I fundamentally I think that
religious education begins with the
stuff that is harder to believe because
that's the most simplest to understand
it's hard to believe and simplest to
understand right the stories in Genesis
are the hardest to believe on their face
but they're also the simplest to
understand like you get from the idea of
Adam and Eve that you are not the
creator of your own meaning right that
you that the knowledge of good and evil
your knowledge of good and evil is not
the same as God's knowledge of good and
evil and that by attempting to create
your own meaning it's a you're actually
egotistically sending against God that's
that's the message of the Adam and Eve
story or the K native and Cain and Abel
story which is that ceaseless jealousy
and a belief in your incapacity to take
control of your life and that results in
violence and cruelty right that's the
basic issue of Cain and Abel which is
God says to Cain you know Tim shell you
can't do this mm-hmm and then Cain's
like no I'm gonna cut my brother like
infants and that's and you see that down
to an aspect of human nature you teach
these very simple stories to people
David versus Goliath
all of this I can beat the big guy right
there there plenty of great stories that
imbed fundamental value because this is
how you teach kids everybody teaches
kids secular and religious you teach
kids stories when I read my daughter at
night I'm not reading her from from
Sam's book she wouldn't understand it
right all right I'm not gonna read her
enlightenment now or
how the mind works my pink are like you
have to start with certain fundamental
values those fundamental values are
generally rooted in story this is where
Jordan is totally correct and those are
deeply embedded in the human psyche and
so there's an immediate resonance to a
lot of the biblical stories which is why
the Bible has staying and selling power
and then you use those stories in
coordination with reason to expand those
stories outward and to develop right but
you have to always stay tethered I mean
it's you can lengthen the chain but at a
certain point the chain breaks and then
you're off and running and then you got
a problem that the point that I'm making
here is that I think the West has has
undercut its own allegiance to
fundamental principle and they thought
that this would allow the rise of reason
to dominate and what it's instead
allowed for is in the worst cases some
really horrible things and in the best
cases yes a continuation of material
prosperity but also in a crisis of
purpose and meaning that's happening to
people where they're looking around ok
ok I'm up I'm a ball of meat wandering
through the universe purpose list I
don't have very well I don't have the
capacity to to control my own life what
am I supposed to do now so I think
basically you're saying is you think it
could work for a while that Atkins alone
could work for a certain amount of as
long as it's living off the fumes of the
judeo-christian ethic and this is the
point that I made to Sam when we debated
in San Francisco was I said you know Sam
why is it that we hold the same values
maybe cuz we do we found a fundamental
level we have basically the same values
so why and he said well I've studied
this and I've studied this I've said
Eastern philosophy this is where I get
my values well that's great but why are
ours the same breaks I haven't said any
of those things so why are those the
same and I don't thing it's because I've
studied deeply in the Bible and sam
hasn't I think it's because we both grew
up on the fumes of this culture right
man we grew up ten miles from each other
in Los Angeles that seems to me a better
kind of historical explanation of why we
believe fundamentally the same things
then that he studied one philosophy and
I studied another philosophy Stan do you
think we're in the feud stage now yeah I
think the teams running out yeah The
Jerusalem fumes and I think that as the
Jerusalem fumes run out so do the so do
the the great hopes that were behind the
reason based enlightenment meaning that
one of the points that I make is that
the Enlightenment makes fundamental
assumptions that are unsustainable on
the grounds of the Enlightenment meaning
the Enlightenment argued the second one
enlightenment and the non American Anglo
enlightenment makes the argument that
basically we are Spinoza's stone where
our ball of meat wandering through the
universe no will of our own no free will
I mean Sam wrote an entire book about
their not being free well and that we
don't have the capacity to choose and
when Sam talks about reason as I asked
him before like so according to
evolutionary biology reason is just a
beneficial firing of the neurons but you
make a moral argument in favor of reason
so my question is on what basis what if
there is a more evolutionarily
beneficial firing of the neurons say
genocide I mean
genocide nitin this is Hitler's
rationale effectively mm-hmm just apply
Darwinism to the social sphere and we
can effectively wipe out everybody who
we don't like and that will better
humanity by getting rid of the weaklings
and we can move on at us also correct
Diana's had Thanos is on board with this
yeah
by the way Tanis has an infinity son
right isn't just create more resources
anyway if you met a genie what's the
first thing you wish for in any case the
the fundamentals of the Enlightenment
which are reason free will the capacity
to make your own decisions are actually
robbed by scientific materialism if
you're a scientific materialist I don't
know how you sustain the bit like Sam
says he believes an objective truth I
agree with Sam their subjective truth
it's fascinating Jordan doesn't believe
in objective truth in the same way right
Jordan believes in a sort of Charles
Pierce Charles Perce pragmatism with
regard to truth that truth is whatever
works mhm
and so there's certain things that have
been proved to work and those are true
which is attractively useful for
evolutionary biology Sam believes an
objective truth like there's an actual
truth out there to be discovered there
are things that are true and there are
things that are false I totally agree
with him and believe that but not for
the same well I don't know well as I
asked him I don't know what his reason
is meaning Sam says that stuff and I
don't mean to rip on Sam but I mean I
talk about all this in the book and I'm
sure he can read a really cogent
response cuz he's a bright guy and I
really like his stuff you know we should
do it when Sam's here so we can discuss
it but it's but the the fundamental
point that I make is if you are going to
argue in favor of reason if you're gonna
argue in favor of will if you're gonna
argue in favor of all of these things
you need to make some fundamental
assumptions that are simply not
protected truth evolutionary biology
doesn't speak to objective truth it
speaks to what is useful to a species
that allows it to survive and thrive but
it doesn't speak to what's true if the
species didn't exist what two plus two
equals four would be true Sam would say
yes and I would say why because the
species doesn't exist to use it so what
what does that even mean there's the
judeo-christian ethics and this is where
Greek teleology in judeo-christian
ethics made you know the Greeks
Aristotle Plato they believed there was
such a thing as an objective truth they
believed that there was such a thing as
a universe that a cosmos that is
understandable they believed in the idea
of free will that you could make a
difference in the cosmos then believe
in it you would say it's just not enough
right right just believing in the in the
rational mind is still not enough right
and then when they that is a type of
belief right and I think that they
attempt to they attempt to prove back to
you know the unmoved mover and that's a
good starting point this is why Aquinas
is so reliant on Aristotelian theology
and the same thing is true for
Maimonides they both like the the the
greatest I think attempt historically to
merge the religious philosophy of
judeo-christianity and the and the Greek
philosophy of Aristotle and Plato is
simultaneously done in the Islamic world
and the Christian world and the Judaic
world actually it's done by Al Farabi
and the in the Islamic world and it's
done by Maimonides in the Judaic world
and it's done by by Aquinas in the in
the Christian world and that's an
attempt to merge but in the merger you
you sort of lose the tension that's
necessary I think because when you
completely merge then it and you end up
in the same place as that as the
theocratic
okay so natural law and theology are
exactly the same so let's just follow up
theology my rhuebottom bothering with
this reasoning it out thing there's no
reason to do that I think the tension
exists for a reason so then getting us
back then how do we get out of this
thing this this polarization that we
seem to be in which I do think I think
you got it right here it is the tension
between these two cities right now so
how do we break this because we're all
sort of caught in it and I've also been
thinking about something that we've
talked about a bunch before that we're
running out of communal spaces or
communal events to have anything left to
bring us together nobody really watches
the nightly news anymore we're after
Game of Thrones goes off after this yeah
that's we're basically out of TVs and
anyway and we're stuck with and we're
stuck with cultural events not actual
meaning based events right we don't have
a go into the we don't have a moon
landing coming up you know we're really
running short on
I mean July 4th Marines are
controversial yeah yeah you're you're
parading genocide or something I mean
it's all nuns it's but that that as this
tension ramps up the fact that we're now
have no spaces to let the vents off that
seems to me to be the biggest danger
totally agree and and this is not just
you know people on the right saying this
people on the left are recognizing this
and Robert Putnam is a sociologist at
Harvard he writes this great book called
Bowling Alone and in it he talks about
the the sort of
diversity is our strength and he says he
I used to believe the Stuber cities are
strength stuff and then I looked at the
social science and what I found is that
it's ethnic diversity in a place
increases the only two things that
increase are protests marches and
television watching unless unless
there's a common purpose if there is a
common purpose then that versity is your
strength so in other words if you go to
a church and you look at the church
function diverse faces people with
different experiences but they're all
there to have a common purpose worship
God and take care of each other then
diversity is great all the experiences
you can tell each other about it you
have the same goal that's all fantastic
he says the same thing about the army
you go to the army and you see an
incredibly diverse group of people I
mean we know we both know a lot of
people who serve in the military and the
the amount of cross racial friendship in
the military is amazing right for people
who just grew up in secular society and
where it's like yeah I have my black
friend and it but that's not true in the
military in the military then people
legitimately bond across races because
they're forced into proximity where they
are like sports nobody can direct
escort's is another great example right
they they have the same common goal well
so the question becomes for our society
what is our common goal and it seems
like that common goal is receding
because some of the fundamental things I
think that we are all supposed to agree
on right the free speech democracy the
use of free will the use of
responsibility even things as
fundamental as that are dissipating in
response to people saying you know what
all this is a lie the only way to attain
power and protection for my group is
return to tribalism which is
intersectionality on the one hand and
and white supremacy on the other or we
are going to get rid of all of this
stuff in the name of the collective
because the individual no longer matters
like the I talk in the in the book about
this kind of fourfold matrix for human
happiness that we all exist as human
beings on a couple of levels as members
of as individuals and then as members of
community and we are all these things
right I mean we people will say the
Communist will say you're just a member
of the community basically and then
libertarians will say you're only an
individual and the truth is neither of
those things you are a member of a
community and you are an individual and
they're simultaneous and inextricable
and so you need to so the human
happiness in individual exists when you
have the following four things and in a
society can exist we have the following
four things individual individual
purpose so you get up in the morning
you're on a desert island what do you do
today
are you nihilistic do you have
something to do what makes what gives
you meaning communal purpose meaning
what can we all get together to do and
what's our goal together as America are
we here to spread Liberty are we here to
preserve Liberty are we here to create
economic equality what is our goal as a
community and how do we not quash
individual purpose in that there has to
be a balance right because if communal
purpose is too strong you quash the
individual and then there's individual
capacity you have to feel like you as a
person are in control of your own life
capable of forging forth into the kind
of adventure and wilderness which is the
American mentality and you have to have
communal capacity a system that allows
me to as an individual thrive well
allowing us as a community to mobilize
when need be if you have these four
things then you can be a happy
individual and you can be have a happy
Society now the way I think this is best
balanced in terms of government is that
government is weak enough not to attack
you as an individual but is strong
enough to mobilize when you really need
to mobilize to protect those individual
rights and to protect the the system at
large that's that's what I think the
founders got it exactly right it's why I
think that I rely to a very heavy extent
on the social fabric as opposed to
government to create a fake social
fabric I think the left relies on the
government to create a sense of
community I don't feel a sense of
community in government I don't care
about the people in government I don't
think they care about me I think that
the people who care about me are in my
family in my community I think the
brought the more broadly we share values
the more I care about people in the
broader community but there's a sense on
the left it the way that we created
social fabric is by having a very
powerful government in 2012 I was at the
DNC when they flashed on the overhead
screen that the government is the only
thing that we all be only the government
is the only thing we all share and I
thought to myself well that's a great
bunch of flash that on the TV yeah yeah
it's like 1984 right it was very it was
it was really late I saw it I can't
believe that this is a thing that's up
on the screen the only thing we all
share really like that's that's where
we're all participating together because
it seems to me that we all shared a
bunch of different things and the fewer
things we engage in the more we're gonna
need to rebuild that capacity from
outside in I don't like outside in
composing what do we do then about the
nationwide or Nady it's not even nation
like it's worldwide now I mean the
themes that were after this last year or
being on tour the same things that we're
talking about here all the time within
an American context are happening in
virtually every Western society at some
level so what do we do
to rebuild some of those those common
public spaces what what is it we should
be doing so I think that so that they're
they're a couple things one the
government really needs to stop tearing
down religious institutions because
historically speaking religious
institutions have been the bulwark of
the social networks that most people
rely on and we living in big cities
don't tender line it as much but out in
the sticks people really rely on the
stuff it's one more push for my atheist
viewers and my leftist shores that may
remain or the progressives can you give
them one more push on why they shouldn't
fear that okay you shouldn't fear that
because so long as there's not
government compulsion from religious
people in religious communities towards
others the fact that people are
belonging to churches is a wonderful
thing they're supporting each other
they're giving charity to each other
they're they're making sure that you
don't have to pay for them they're the
ones who are making sure that there is a
social fabric people can rely upon you
want less opioid overdoses you want you
want less people who are unemployed and
unemployable
you won't less people who are following
and following in the deaths of despair
they need a social fabric you're not
creating it and don't pretend you are
you're sitting in the city far away from
these people and when you rip on their
church and when you suggest that their
church is the obstacle you're taking
away the one connection to social fabric
that people have Tim Carney has a new
book called alienated America in which
he looks at various communities when he
finds is that it's not even an economic
thing people on the left and the right
populace are like well we can fix all
this with the kind of economics we just
put some tariffs here we'll put some
subsidies here we grant universal basic
income that's gonna fill this gap for
these people the question is not lack of
benefits there are unemployment benefits
there's welfare their food stamps
there's plenty of benefits available for
a lot of people that's not the question
the question is where do you find
connection with other human beings and
while you can sit in a place where you
feel like you have connection and
especially if you're a college graduate
who's watching this show in a big city
you do have a near sat social connection
like a different kind of intersects
isn't right a different kind of social
connection with people you want to
college with and people you hang out
with that doesn't exist in huge swaths
of the country and the firt the first
place people go to get connection is
their church when those churches
disappear the communities die and then
people there are left without even the
motivation to move so that that's one
thing that then secular but again this
is not restricted to religious people
like me who are saying this they're
Robert Putnam is a secular guy he says
you get rid of the church you got a real
problem on your hands there are plenty
of sociologists who are looking at the
death of churches and saying what's
gonna fill this gap well I see it
I mean I don't come from that default
position necessarily but I do see it now
I mean after being with Jordan on this
tour the when he would talk about the
the importance of the stories of
religion I could see people there
there's it's not a coincidence that
people could start thinking about these
stories the messages and these stories
and then suddenly there were thousands
of people that I was meeting that were
they stopped doing drugs and they
stopped drinking as write amends with
their children or I mean every day I saw
this this is Aranda and this is I can't
be a coincidence and this is the other
element of that we really need to
re-encode Kate and that is that the
smart people don't have all the
solutions but the one thing that you can
do is solve your own problems and this
is this isn't mindset thing so on notice
that everything that I'm saying has
nothing to do with governmental
compulsion it's the opposite I want the
government out of everything because I
don't think the compulsion is gonna fix
any of this the the biggest thing that
needs to change is people need to
reimburse the spirit of adventure in
their own lives and this is something
that I really believe that this is the
thing that makes Jordan most popular so
this is what Jordan says life is a
struggle life is chaotic life is
difficult go and forge forth in spite of
those things and this is what makes you
a man right this is what makes you a
woman this is what makes you a person
worthy of having freedom I think that's
true I think it's fundamentally a
religious message in nature and it's
certainly an inspirational one and we
have a society where basically said to
people no you know what you got a
problem I can solve it for you the smart
people will solve it for you we'll solve
it through ubi we'll solve it through
tariffs well solve it through through
going after China and Mexico you're
never gonna have to leave your hometown
it was I had this conversation with
Tucker Carlson and Tucker's a really
interesting dude and we were talking
about specifically his sort of anti tech
take so he's he's very concerned about
self-driving trucks
destroying millions of jobs I'm a little
bit more sanguine about that I don't
think it's gonna happen overnight I
think that you still need drivers behind
the wheels but in any case he was
there's one point from a conversation
when Tucker said something to the effect
of you know you're gonna say to a bunch
of people who are living in the town
where their grandparents are buried that
they need to pick up and move and when
I'm saying is they should be able to
stay there and have jobs and I said
right like this is the he said you want
them to leave the town where they're
where their parents are where their
grandparents died and I said right or
biblically speaking leave the land of
your father's and go to a land that you
know
right I mean this is the spirit of the
individual forging forth is what made
the country fantastic one statistic that
is just utterly astonishing is that in
an era where we have this rising
underclass of folks who have sort of
been left behind we have less mobility
in the United States than any time in
modern American history people are
leaving home less often and they didn't
people are saying well it's cuz they're
living with their parents fine why
aren't they moving where the jobs are I
mean this was literally what every one
of our parents did right I mean I know
where your parents grew up mines it my
parents grew up in Chicago and they
moved to Boston and they moved to LA
Brooklyn right exactly like everyone in
California's original story was that no
one was born in California rightly very
like I was born in LA I'm one of the
only people I knew who's born in LA
right this is and and that that sort of
movement this this hunger to go out
there and adventure and take control of
your own life that needs to be
reincarnated and that comes we have to
tide against did you move him on that at
all because I know that I'm on Tucker
tonight yeah I went on all the time when
I have these discussions with him and
I'm did you move him on that I'm not
sure I don't really well right I mean
this is a fad right don't care about
your feelings thank you what he's saying
there it does feel right like if your
whole family if your family lived in a
town right mining town for a hundred
years it doesn't feel right I mean this
is right I would say about the Baker and
the and the gay wedding cake it's like
it doesn't feel right that you can't get
the right there but that doesn't mean
that the government should fix the
problem right or come and fix them right
and and this is and again I think that
there's mentality shift that's happening
it's true of immigration so I think has
real policy ramifications this idea that
you were born in America therefore
you're owed a bunch of stuff and I just
don't think that that's frankly I'd only
get a good perspective I think on a
religious level to another religious
perspective in my perspective is that
you're effectively owed nothing right
you're owed you're owed the adventure
you're owed the freedom to be able to do
what it is that you want to do and then
the reason you need the social fabric is
to help the people who can't do it
without the hand up and it's it's funny
you talk to people who live in religious
communities and because they've had the
social fabric they instinctively feel
like the government has filled a lot of
the social fabric and in a lot of big
cities but you talk to people who live
in religious communities and everyone
has a story that's like this where it's
like there was somebody in the community
who's struggling so the rabbi got
together a bunch of people they gave him
some money I think I knew
the money came from and he went out and
he made a plan and he fixed it and and
that was the way that things got fixed
now is that gonna fill every single gap
no I mean you do need local government
sometimes to fill these gaps local is
better than national because you have
more sympathy with people who live close
to you and you see the impact of the
problem where you live but the the idea
that you need a social fabric it's why I
don't consider myself libertarian even
though a libertarian on social on
government policy because I think that
the mistake that some libertarians make
is to suggest that libertarianism
applies on a social level too right so
that's right limited government in and
of itself is enough to keep everything
going right and I don't think that I
don't think that's correct I mean I
think that
rights and duties are two sides of the
same coin and as Washington suggested
that you know you need a moral people to
sustain liberty so it's a bit of a non
sequitur sort of but maybe not so do you
think this is why the left is going so
bananas with the Jews at the moment that
there's some connection there because
Jews did get up and when I mean riding
that conversation with Tucker I was
thinking that's the end of Fiddler on
the Roof right I don't want to leave
when exactly to lazer wolf you know they
don't want to leave I'm going to Chicago
you're going wherever and right but it's
like we have to go now we have to forge
something new and Jews had kind of been
doing that for everyone that is the
antithesis of what the left is offering
now so I think there is truth to that
and I don't think it's restricted to
Jews I think that you've seen the
intersectional hierarchy change
radically based on which minority groups
are perceived to be more successful so
what you see is the is the left
suggesting that Asians are no longer
minorities in the United States can't
get into the heart rate you can't get
into Harvard you're not you're not truly
on the intersectional scale because
you're and now they're doing okay sorry
gave Asians everything that they came in
right he segments Asians and Indians
just get everything they were just you
know working these hard jobs and running
little hotdog stands and 7-elevens just
exactly exactly and then worked hard and
you see this is happening on the fringe
left already with with gay folks right
so the idea that you saw that article at
Slate where they did this boot with
Buddha judge where they were like well
it's an intersectional enough because he
grew up white and he grew up privileged
and he went to good schools but also
he's case he's a little intersectional
right it's not like intersect is
oppressed does he write it was a
repression
this counts as a gay guy it was
legitimately citycam as a gay guy I
think was that was sort of the headline
was like he's not fully like I don't
understand well he's married to a man so
last I checked yeah I mean like well
first of all I'm not even sure what
they're going for there except for he
doesn't rate high enough on the in the
oppression sale
well the craziest one of those that I
ever saw was a couple years ago I think
it was it was either out magazine or
advocate I can't remember which one when
they said that Peter teal is no longer
gay right because his politics don't
line up with gay so what would really
make you gay the physical part no no
that does fact doesn't matter what
matters is how we feel man you're gonna
by the way they'll come after Carla
Harris on the same grounds her one
parent is Jamaican one parent is Indian
I mean that's that's not traditional
grew up in the inner city
I mean her dad I think was a professor
at Stanford or something like no comfor
for anybody who doesn't like one will
pretend intersectionality applies until
it no longer applies does that make you
very hopeful then because I think we're
seeing minority groups crack we're
seeing Asians go whoa we don't never got
the reverse side of this Jews are
finally going way we don't have to vote
80 percent Democrat black people I mean
just the fact that now reparations is
becoming virtually every Democratic
candidate now talking about reparations
to me regardless I know you have a
little bit of a love-hate thing with
Candace Owens but it's like she did it
I'm just like Candace no no I don't it's
like what I mean you guys you guys go at
it and that's fine I think more it's
like I just said here and sometimes she
doesn't maybe likes you I meant more
that you don't you don't agree on
everything that correct you know point
being when I see all these Democrats
suddenly going we should have a
commission to figure our reparations
it's like whoa Candace really must have
done something here within the black
community because now all they're going
is all we got left is cash well I think
that they're yeah I hope that that's
true you know I I don't know the data
bear it out but I certainly hope that
there is that cracking that is taking
place but the left has a couple of very
powerful forces and one of them is as we
discussed the attempt to make it
uncomfortable to have different thoughts
or to engage with people who have
different thoughts that you are no
longer welcome in the circle of the
the woke if you have a conversation with
somebody on there I mean legitimately
have a conversation or watch a video I
mean there's a story that was out of
name is Michigan State two weeks ago
where a student at Michigan State
College fix reported this was watching
one of my videos on YouTube and the
roommate made and made a rights
violation complaint to the
administration at Michigan State for the
student watching my video and the
administrators like fine we'll move you
I mean like yeah like it's come to the
point where if you mention names like
people who legitimately don't know
anything about you don't know anything
about Candice don't anything about me
you don't know anything about Jordan
they'll make claims about people they
legitimately cannot back up cuz they'd
never engaged with their content but the
very fact that they haven't engaged with
the content is their credibility on
speaking on the content because if they
ever engaged on the content then they
wouldn't believe all these things but
they don't engage and therefore they are
good lack of engagement is good right
it's not that you engaged now you're
better because you've had a better
conversation if you didn't engage or
better so those are the that's the
countervailing intimidation factor
that's that's taking place and that I
think is still quite powerful it's why
every single Democratic candidate I mean
it really is incredibly powerful every
single Democratic candidate effectively
skipped a pack this year
yeah because Ilhan Omar has impact and
because folks on the and because folks
on the hard left hate Israel and and
that has impact and then they all showed
up for Al Sharpton who's legitimately
one of the worst people in modern
American POW it's like in modern
American history theater he he ran a
justice Millette hoax and accused an
actual human being of committing a rape
against a black girl who was not raped
he accused even Pagonis of raping a
black girl and then scrawling racial
slurs on her body in [ __ ] and he is it
was not it was all false and he was he
called Jews diamond merchants he he
suggested white interlopers were taking
over Freddie's fashion Mart and their
and then somebody went and burned down
the place like he's the worst guy I'll
sharpen then every Democrat showed up at
the National Action Network because to
be woke means to be in the club like we
don't here's the thing about those of us
in the IDW people think that we have a
club it's it's not a club it's just
people who like to talk about things and
anybody is welcome to the club which is
why you see like these weird videos
where people who we've never talked to
her had conversations with are suddenly
quote unquote members of the IDW like
we talk with each other and there's like
a core group I think of us who every so
often like really every so often go out
and get drinks or have dinner but that's
like that's not a that's not the same
thing as this
you're unwelcome in the club if you
don't if you don't do acts like that's
the weird thing that if the if this way
if the IDW let's say whatever it is at
the moment you're right it's not a call
when I walk around with a card we don't
have a clubhouse you know okay well like
if this collection and of course it's
way wider than just us but if this
middle collection which seemingly it's
pretty small in it and it's kind of
getting smaller because it's it's just
getting tougher to have centrist opinion
right and this thing doesn't hold yeah I
mean that's right after what and and
what you can see and you can see how
viciously the left is trying to carve it
apart by what they'll do is they'll come
after me and then they'll ask you for
comment or they'll come after Sam then
the last me for comment or they'll
Jordan and I'll go after it but that's
why I think it's important I know you
know people attacking oh he's always
he's always [ __ ] on the left but
it's like this is the perfect example of
what's going on here on the right does
anyone on the right relentlessly
viciously and dishonestly attack the
Weinstein brothers or or Sam even or
anyone that's on the left they don't I
mean they agree to disagree if you read
that really is as simple as I mean it's
amazing if you read the comments on the
I take yang as an example because it
just happened but if you read the
comments on the Sunday special that I
did with you Aang there is nothing like
legitimately that I never read the
comments but as curious there is nothing
but appreciation that yang would even
come on the show yeah that's the entire
thing it's like oh look a cordial
conversation between people who disagree
that's so nice
like how pathetic is it that that is
considered like the big win here there
was there wasn't a single comment about
like ah Shapiro destroyed gang that
wasn't the purpose of it everybody got
what it was supposed to be it's a
conversation and that's great did he
view on anything like a you bi situation
right I'd read his book and I and I
didn't find it utterly convincing on a
you bi I think that as I've said before
when it comes to you bi if we reach the
point of absolute crisis where nothing
else is like it let's put this way you
bi as negative income tax in lieu of all
of the welfare systems we currently have
I would sign on to a new heart beat
mmhmm right the idea if we get rid of we
get rid of real repeal and replace right
if you repeal all the welfare programs
in your place it with a single check
that is signed then but I think the
promises of UB are a little bit too big
for its britches so people are saying
well it'll solve the opioid epidemic or
it'll solve the as I
say in the book I think it's a crisis of
meaning not a crisis of money and so I
don't think that's gonna solve it if the
idea is that people are going to be
liberated as Andrew says in his book to
go and do art and volunteering and
charity I don't see any evidence of
that's the part I don't write that's the
power I was like no you know even if you
could get me on the robots are replacing
all our regular job alright let's say
you could get me on maybe the other part
is just that it takes away something
about fundamental human nature about
what you're talking about before about
the individual going out there and
getting theirs right you would just end
up having this class of people that
would be given just enough I mean I have
a new welfare right exactly and what he
said was well it's not enough to
actually live on it's just enough to
actually supplement and what I said is
so what's the limiting principle like
isn't just the 1,000 or is a politician
ever come around next week and say it
ought to be 3,000 and then you have what
did he say about because I haven't he
didn't he didn't really I don't really
firmly addressed it because that's the
question right it's right oh okay we can
also sandbox and we're good it correct
literally the next week
there will be somebody who says a
thousand and what are they gonna say
about the lefties who want a thousand
they'll call them racist or that's
exactly right no I mean that there are
some problems in implementation of ubi
that exists with the welfare state also
a lot of the studies that suggest that
there's the same level of employment
those are temporary ubi attempts right
if they were permanent ubi I think that
you would see a decline in employment
but also as I said to him there's a
conflict between what ubi says it's
trying to do and what it actually would
do so I think it would do the same thing
as the welfare state and that's why I
say like as a replacement for the
welfare state I'm kind of warm to it by
just like let's give it a shot basically
that's right and also because I'd rather
have the government sign an
understandable cheque rather than you
have to go through you have to Dede
incentivize work or de incentivize
fatherhood or you know all these
incentive based structures I'm not a fan
and they've been rather ineffective but
but as a general principle the idea that
it's gonna solve the work crisis what he
talked about in his book is the crisis
of people who don't have jobs and that
crisis is not having up the job not
merrily they're not having of the money
deciding people up track in lieu of a
job doesn't actually like he points out
in the book number of people on
disabilities been rising dramatically
right they're all getting a check and
are they happy are they spending their
time volunteering are they spending
their time down
Waystation helping people or are they
you know like it all sounds good
Medicare for all it sounds good we will
write have the same thing now we know
that that's not going to be the case
because of course well now they're
talking about getting rid of private
insurance which is insane I mean that's
fully what they have to do it because
otherwise doctors just will not accept
Medicare reimbursement rights I mean
that's the reality again you know as
somebody who works closely with people
in the medical industry and in fact
sleeps with a person in the medical
industry you know that you know the the
idea that doctors are gonna just accept
60% on the dollar of what they're making
right now is absolute sheer nonsense but
also it's such a disconnect of what of
what I think they view I mean I get it
that they think government is something
that I don't think it should be but it's
like what right would the government
have to tell a doctor he can't be in the
private business that he wants to be in
right and they they actually think
that's okay I mean quite literally
ramallah and I think Cory Booker and I
think it's and they think it's a good
private insurer well I mean this is
another there's another thing that I
asked you about cuz he said he was for
Medicare for all and there's a section
his book where he says so how are we
gonna deal with the fact that doctors
are going to just stop going to medical
school cuz that's a real thing that will
happen I mean already if you want to see
how perverse incentives work in the
medical industry look how many people
come out of medical school and go into
what are called the road the the road
fields is radiology ophthalmology
anesthesiology and dermatology why those
are the least regulated fields there's
the least Medicare there nobody's taking
reimbursement rates those are all areas
where people basically show up with an
insurance company or cash in hand that's
where everybody's going where all the
money is so that's how perverse
incentives work he says in the book well
we're gonna have to convince doctors
that basically they need to rethink
about what the lifestyle of a doctor is
going to be that they're not going to
live high on the hog anymore that
they're going to you know be putting out
more for the public service and then
well you can do that but it's not only
the same people if you think how to do
that no I mean he sort of says that we
should that we should just people will
will have to be informed that the
incentive structure is different and
here's the thing if you have a different
incentive structure you're going to get
a different thing my wife would not have
gone to medical school if you were
assured I've come for 11 years if you're
assured of coming out making sixty five
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars right the reality is that you
wanted a certain lifestyle that's why
she went to medical school you changed
those incentives you think all these
guys are going into
surgeons are gonna spend years on end
doing this so they can then work for
years on end working for Medicare does
that sound awesome to anyone like this
is the reason that smart people become
doctors is because smart people would
like to make money and be paid for their
work this is why smart like yes there is
a self-sacrificial component to all of
this it's there are easier ways to make
money than being a doctor but to
eliminate the money factor is to
eliminate half the reason that people
become doctors in the first place you
want a lot more people who are lawyers
and McKinsey associates this is the way
to do it I have a good friend what
probably two or three best friends from
childhood since second grade who was
like my chief sparring political partner
our whole lives and he's now become a
huge Trump supporter and why because he
was a doctor went to medical school
raised all the debt realized he could
never live in New York where he grew up
he's now in Texas and he's often doing
things that have not to make money now
because it's really hard and then he
became a trump supporter because of
Obamacare because he was crushed with
paperwork and bureaucracy and nonsense
and now to make money because it's so
much harder than just doing the
procedures he's basically doing like
like medical real estate things yeah and
it just shows you that the whole system
and that's just one guy but it's like
yeah well system is a door where doctors
are going into concierge care
specifically because of this yeah I mean
there are full apps that exist where
you're paying like 99 bucks a month and
then a doctor will show up at your door
like there are so many ways that we
could make medical care so by mean
online should be such an asset for
medical care right we should there's so
many would getting rid of licensing
requirements as I suggest it would be a
great thing like there there are things
that we can actively do to do this and
the truth is for healthy people and for
people who have private health care
insurance there really isn't a problem
like we like to talk about how it's too
expensive why do you think we have
millions and millions of jobs in the
healthcare industry like what do they
think happens when they nationalize this
thing all those jobs just transfer over
to government or are a lot of those jobs
lost because those people don't work for
anybody right anymore
why is it that people ignore the upsides
of what what do they think does anyone
answer that question what are you going
to do with all those people not the
private no and all be hired by the
government to do nothing right and today
and nobody seems to understand that the
the reason that the majority of new
drugs and procedures are discovered in
the United States is because we're
paying those outside prices so when
Trump says that we are paying for
everybody else that is true we are
paying for everybody else but if we stop
paying for everybody else they just
we'll stop producing those drugs here
because why else would they produce the
drugs here like this is our system is
not good but to pretend that our system
is like the worst system on planet Earth
or the people are done I mean quick
statistic that nobody likes to cite but
is true if you get rid of shooting of
homicides and car accident death when
people die like at the scene from the
American death rates America is the
number one life expectancy in the
industrialized world those are not
medical issues those are issues of
people shooting each other and people
get in car wrecks a lot here in the
United States so you know that's and as
far as that spending per capita like
insane amounts of money we spend more
than other countries it is relatively in
line with the OECD income so fervor on a
per capita income basis we spend a lot
of money we also make a lot of money
here in the United States and the
medical industry here is a huge part of
the American economy all of Pittsburgh
is basically the medical industry now as
opposed to the steel industry and that
is a very good thing for Pittsburgh so
the answer to a lot of this is
deregulation not reregulate but again
those are conversations I think that can
be happened I think that people are not
being realistic about what they expect
from the system and they're not
realistic about the downsides of systems
that are that are completely
nationalized I mean in my opinion if
you're actually gonna get the government
deeply involved we've got to have a
Swiss system where basically people are
paying a percentage of their salary into
private insurance and then they are and
then they are expected to do that right
like the individual mandate if you're
gonna get the government involved is not
the world's worst idea it's just that
it's now stacked with enormous amounts
of regulation and inefficiency and
bureaucratic inefficiency and that but I
think again that a free market is better
than any of that stuff but I also think
that you ought to take responsibility if
you are on it if you don't buy insurance
then you get hit by a car I'm sorry that
that would be a you problem like that
that's why we need a social fabric where
I care about you yeah but on a
governmental level this idea that you're
not going to increase the rates of use
with government care is just a lie right
people are going to pay for those people
no matter what right I mean right once I
turn them around at the emergence right
right but getting getting hit by the car
is usually not the real issue usually
the real issue is how do you pay for the
person who didn't buy health insurance
for years and then gets in gets hard
condition that requires you know here's
long care
the Otters can get paid for that we all
end up paying for it with an elevated
insurance rates and all the rest of it
but you know the the problem of the
chronically unhealthy which is a very
small percentage of the population but
the most expensive percentage that is
not really a rationale for overturning
health care that 90% of people seem to
enjoy like it also is gonna make you
hate people for no reason you're gonna
go to in-and-out or McDonald's and see a
table of for obese people stuffing their
faces drinking - or in syrup and
everything else and you're gonna go wait
a minute these people are all there
living well this is horrible it's no one
wants to look at that and think that
well this is this is this is why you
know I've said people who try to compare
for example the Nordics the Nordic
healthcare model to the u.s. healthcare
model you're not comparing equivalent
populations people eat healthy things in
Norway people in the United States eat
nothing but crap all the time I was just
in Norway Sweden Finland Denmark these
people who look good
right I mean this is it's a it's a much
healthier population and this is why if
you actually want to compare the
efficacy of health care systems you
don't look at the generalized population
of the United States and the generalized
population of Norway they're all so
absurdly tiny country right that with
five million people I mean the LA County
is 11 million people or something right
what you do is you compare people who
are Norwegian in America to people who
are Norwegian in Norway and what you
find is that people in who are Norwegian
and America outperform on nearly every
aspect people who are Norwegian in
Norway then you are comparing apples to
apples like you we compare apples to
oranges and then we're like well why
doesn't this work over here because
they're not the same thing that's why it
doesn't work over here
all right Shapiro let's go dystopian
you're ready okay let's say everything
that you've written about here
everything that we're trying to do all
these conversations well having at all
it all just explodes it yeah it does not
work we the ideas that we're fighting
for fail in the face of post-modernism
of what's being taught at this colleges
of what the media is throwing at
everybody and we get more and more of
these people in government and all of
these things I think about this
sometimes that what will happen to the
outlier people like us in the future do
you ever think about that but I think
that right now for example for all these
people that think Trump is Hitler and
all this stuff
Trump tweets anything and then a hundred
blue cheque journalists tell him to go
[ __ ] himself and you're gonna be in jail
and a zillion
and Trump does nothing that's not even a
defense of anything Trump says that's
just reality
but now let's do it the other way
imagine now we've got one of these far
lefties yeah Bernie's believe that
government is the end-all be-all to
everything and now the outliers who have
all been called Nazis all along right
the Ben Shapiro's and everybody else
that have been called the worst things
about now now government and tech is
against us and now we're doing the same
exact things that the lefties of today
are doing yeah how do you think that's
gonna go well I mean this is why at
Daily wire and I know you've been
looking into this too alternative means
of distribution are the entire ballgame
I mean though that we understand that
when it comes to the left you cannot
live on their largesse and like for
God's sake at the beginning of the year
they came after me and tried to boycott
me over making the most anodyne points
on abortion I think I've ever made in my
life right they they try to they
generally try to knock my sponsors off
my show yeah for suggesting that pro
lifers don't want to kill any baby no
matter what that baby would turn out to
be because we don't believe that you can
kill babies for any rationale based on a
Minority Report reasoning and I
mentioned baby Hitler in this context
because that been a thought experiment
that was used by people up to and
including Tom Hanks for legitimately
years and they tried to boycott my show
based on that I mean was insane then so
we're not focusing on living on the
largesse of the left when it comes to
this sort of stuff we're building a
subscription system at Daily wire this
is why we encourage people to subscribe
because then you can get our content no
matter what you do because we it's all
vertically integrated I know that you're
looking at stuff like that as well you
know on a tech level we're building
alternatives and that's what we ought to
be doing on a generalized level I think
what we're watching and it's really
pretty sad is that people like us are
gonna end up in places with people who
agree with people like us meaning that I
live in a Jewish community where I'm
pretty popular because it's an orthodox
community I'm Orthodox it's a lunch with
you were to coach your place and if I
had to take one more picture you I was
gonna kill ya exactly I mean that's
that's yeah those are my folks but I've
spent my entire life living in Los
Angeles a place where the vast majority
people disagree with me or in Cambridge
where everyone disagrees with that and
that's and I like that I think it's nice
I think like I think it's good that
there are conversations happening across
the aisle as the left seeks to basically
censor or destroy anyone who even
engages in those conversations where Joe
Rogan become
all right because he has a conversation
with me because I once had a
conversation with you and you once had a
conversation with Alex Jones right like
this is the way that it works clearly
we've all pushed people to the extreme
right and this is and so once that
happens all it's gonna happen is it's
gonna make places like this unlivable
for people like us and I mean even
people who just want to have
conversations and then you do end up
with a real gap in the country that is
almost unbridgeable where it's like
everyone agrees in one place and nobody
agrees in another place and that's where
the if the that's why honestly the
checks and balances system is so vital
we've mentioned before because people in
Texas feel like they're running being
run roughshod over by people in
California in the national government or
the other way around that's not gonna
last that's not that's not sustainable
right so that's why it's like I don't
really like doing this as a thought
experiment more than like what could
potentially happen but it seems to me
that if we have then no Co spaces that
we were talking about right or and we
also do have to get siphoned off into
our own thing just because that's the
way the tech landscape is gonna work
that it's like yeah we got the checks
and balances and our system is pretty
damn good I would say yeah it's terribly
I would say it's the best man-made thing
set of ideas probably in the history of
all time but how can it survive in an
information war you know I mean how can
it survive in a time when for all we
know the next whoever runs it for
president isn't going to accept the
results of the election Stacey Abrams
still not accepting the results like
they're they're undermined they claim
Trump wasn't going to accept the rise
election and now it's like that's what
they're doing they're trying to
undermine everything and if we don't
have enough go spaces to work it out
this is this is why we have a very short
window right now to pour resources into
grabbing as many eyeballs as possible
and ensuring that as many people see
countervailing material as possible
because you just don't know when that
window he's gonna slam shut yeah I mean
that really was it you have to grab as
many people as possible and let them
know that there are alternative places
where they can get your stuff because
otherwise you know here's what I'm
concerned about mostly what I'm
concerned about is that you're gonna see
a move by Democrats in Congress and from
the presidency to do exactly what Mark
Zuckerberg wants right where the FCC is
suddenly regulating speech on Facebook
and to relieve the obligations of
Facebook to do it themselves and
suddenly if you are labeled not
right there all right adjacent yeah
based on the fact that you once
interviewed a person who once
interviewed a person who once stood next
to a person who was once wearing a shirt
then you know then you're screwed so
that that's where I I don't think that
the this way you know you and I make the
same distinction I've made a distinction
for years and years between the Liberals
and the left if the left continues to
conquer the Liberals I think that it's
gonna be a rough time ahead and we
better have these alternative methods of
distribution or we're screwed at that
point all right so let's finish with
this then when I was on Candace's show a
week or two ago I said to her you know I
see something so obvious to me that it
you care about ideas if you want to live
in a tolerant pluralistic society all of
those things it's very obvious the
center right basically is where is where
that's at it just is do you think there
is room for people for the center right
say conservatives to have a little more
openness when it comes to like you know
we've had the abortion discussion many
times I mean I'm really struggling with
it and the further that the left goes on
eight-month abortions and all of the and
post life abortions and post life
abortions yeah it is crazy stuff it's
it's making my position incredibly
difficult and I think a lot of I think a
lot of decent liberals are struggling
with this how what do you think the
right should do if you guys want to be a
little more opening a little more
welcoming let's say for people that are
are seeing where tolerance actually
lives right now mhm what do you think
you this is you won on issues like that
cuz I'm not saying that the right has to
be a tone of the only choice partier
right or a pro-choice set of ideas or
anything like that but what what do you
think is is your job well I mean one of
the that is one may be the only issue
that I can think of where the right
generally and I think correctly believes
in government compulsion meaning that
the the basic thesis of the right is
that when a life is threatened then the
government has a right to step in this
is a life that is threatened the
government has a right to step in so
this I'm not sure as a bridgeable gap
what I mean by that is that the the
right can continue to make the case the
right should continue to make the case I
mean it's a case I agree with but I
can't I'm not libertarian on this issue
because I don't think it's a libertarian
issue so I don't mean that the right has
to modify its position I actually don't
mean that what I mean is just that for
the things that might be the difference
is if you were if you were just
looking to collect decks lefties right
now right I mean the group like how do
you welcome those well I mean the here's
here's where I would stop afraid I think
I think most of them have PTSD I read I
think that's what I really believe I
mean the first place to start is why
don't we start with the stuff where we
agree because the truth is that the
checks and balances of the system just
on a practical level the checks and
balances of the system are not going to
allow for full protection of life
anytime soon the the sort of attempts
that have been made on the right to move
in a more pro-life direction have been
incremental at best
and so if listen if that's the issue
that's going to you know bar you from
joining the right than the see issue
that's gonna bar you from joining the
right it's not much I can do about that
but you know we're I'm happy to welcome
anybody to the conversation and you
don't have to agree with me on abortion
to be part of the conversation like I we
you and I don't agree on this and we
have this conversation on a pretty
routine basis I do it all the time so
you know I I don't think that this is in
it as I say there are certain issues
where the right is not going to move and
frankly I don't think the right should
move this is one of those the only
issues but can I make a bold prediction
sure 30 years from now we're gonna be
sitting here doing this hopefully event
bigger probably may well have moved me
on the on the abortion issue and I think
I may have moved you I'm coming to an
anniversary party
what do you think about that I think
it's possibility I mean I'd have to I'd
have to think about that up again the
issue as you know you know not to get
back well-trod territory you know I I
think it would be unlikely that you'd
move me but I can never rule out the
possibility being moved on anything
obviously and again this is this comes
back down to you know the difference
between approving of activity and
approving of human beings and they yeah
I wouldn't if you invited me to a party
on on Friday night I also wouldn't go
right a minute late is not something I
definitely not a Shabbat back
anniversary I think probably as out yeah
a Sunday afternoon a Sunday afternoon
gay ish anniversary like or or maybe
just wow they should have like a
freaking barbecue dude like does
everything
but the party is not gonna be gay it's
just yeah we'll have a barbecue okay
yeah it's gonna happen they're gonna
turn into an orgy back there or
something like gee I don't worry you're
gonna bring out the Village People or
something like that people have parties
just the state well wait wait I'm like
no that's crazy
yeah not as pretty well aware of that
interact and in fact as I said a
thousand times you're happy go out to
dinner my wife your husband happy to go
out to dinner and do any of that stuff
as long as it's not like you know rah
rah here's the thing you think it's
sinful join me in celebrating it like
that's but again that appeals that
applies to a wide variety of sins that I
mean listen it's harder on it's harder
on members of my family that anybody
else like I've said before I wouldn't
attend an intermarriage I think I drew
marries in Andhra won't attend her
marriage so this is exactly the same
issue Shapiro they're giving me the
signal that you heart out I feel like we
did a radio show exactly all right
that's Ben Shapiro daily wire at Ben
Shapiro on Twitter the book is the right
side of history
is it number one on Amazon right now
well it was it was number one on the New
Times list in his first week so he
knocked off Michelle Obama for all week
and then she took revenge in' and not as
picked number three but but for a week
for a week that's the Battle of the left
of the right there all right that's it
thank you ready
you